e
good morning everyone we're going to
open this work session for house finance
division 3 on May 7th at 10 a.m. for the
record my name is representative Moren
Mooney of miramac the vice chair of
division 3 chairing today's work
session so absent today is a
representative Edwards as well as
representative f as well as
representative
Stringham but in replacement today is
representative Leon and Representative
Steven Boyd thank you both for being
here
uh the fact that we need a clerk for
today uh due to representative
stringham's absence is uh an issue uh
representative wer are you willing to I
know you're between committees and so
forth but uh take as much as you can
during that time thank you so
representative Wier will be our uh
replacement clerk
today I know several representatives are
busy introducing other bills in the
Senate and um bouncing back and forth
between divisions one and too so we
appreciate those that are here
today we have 10 bills today uh to work
on that's the purpose of today's session
and they're all scheduled for 10
o'clock obviously that's going to be um
spaced my thought is this uh for
committee members that we my hope my aim
is perhaps 20 minutes of Bill I'm not
going to hold anyone to that here on the
committee here in the audience we're not
going to stop things at 20 minute but I
would say keep it in mind because that's
approximately three bills an hour and
that would take us to uh
lunchtime it's my intention to break at
12:30 for lunch for an hour and then
resume and uh go from there so does
anybody have any thoughts with regards
to that landscape of today's plan
sounds good okay no votes today we're
meeting again on Friday in order to make
recommendations to the Full House
committee that's our purpose as a
division we make recommendations on
bills for then the full finance
committee to take up as a recommendation
to then recommend to the full house so
recommendation votes will occur on this
Friday Also at 10:00 a.m. is I believe
the scheduled time this Friday it's in
the calendar all these bills
incidentally have been published in the
latest calendar uh dated May
3rd all right anything from the members
related to anything at all all
right I'm gonna now uh turn it over to
Mr Ripple who I have discussed with with
regards to this topic we have a surplus
and we have a tremendous amount of bills
that each come with a price tag and so
naturally as the house finance committee
with our particular purpose being the
finances and how much money is there and
how much money we have to spend and how
much can be spent and the total amounts
and so forth it's good to have just a
snapshot of what we're dealing with
before we proceed on today's schedule so
with that Mr Ripple I will introduce
you sure thank you so you should all
have in front of you a document titled
fiscal year 2425 banial budget variance
May of 24 uh it's dated May 3rd and I
believe Mike Kane sent this out to all
the members of Finance last week as well
so I'll just briefly go through this to
give you an update on the state's
current fiscal
status you can see up top where it says
fiscal 25 projected ending balances as
of June 23rd uh this is where the budget
assumed we would end up and as an aside
for division 3's purposes I'll be
focusing on General funds only but you
can see the impact on the education
trust fund here as
well the budget assumed we would end the
bium with a general fund balance of $3.2
million so that's the starting point for
this
document the items below that are
plan I'll ignore the first one 24
beginning fund balances and move on to
the second fiscal year 24 Revenue versus
plan through April and again uh in in
this case I should stress that revenues
are not forward-looking we're not making
any assumptions about the next year plus
worth of revenues uh this is where the
state stands compared to plan as of the
end of last
month and as of the end of last month in
$68.84 estimated
lapse and here actual lapse is a little
bit misleading because the agencies
haven't lapsed anything yet for this
fiscal year so this is itself an
estimate but it's an updated estimate
compared to the ones used during
preparation of the
budget we're assuming based on what Das
has told us that right now agencies will
lapse $ 34.3 million less than we
process the next line is the projected
appropriation variants and these are for
open warrant Appropriations in which the
state has to pay whatever the actual
costs are for example litigation was a
$7 million expense above what we assumed
in the budget uh Corrections Pharmacy
costs which went through the fiscal
committee are $5 million above what we
assumed in the budget so collectively
those appropriation variances assume
will be spending $24.9 million more uh
than expected during development of the
budget
the final item here are legislative
specials also known as bills so far two
of them have passed both bodies uh very
small bills totaling
$200,000 so the net effect of all that
is we'll have a revised ending balance
assuming everything remains as is which
is a big Assumption of $12.6 million at
the end of the banian that's compared to
the budget Assumption of $3.2 million so
as of right now
were $109.4 million to the
positive but I
wouldn't I wouldn't take that number too
literally because there are a lot of big
unknowns for
example uh revenues for the next year
plus but in particular business tax
revenues in May and June those those are
always very big uh months for business
tax revenues and business taxes in
general have been trending down over the
last few months so that's something to
keep an eye
on also obviously the eventual outcome
of the YDC court case and any subsequent
court cases could have a big impact on
this figure and also the final agency
laps impact uh laps figures could impact
this in One Direction or the other so
that $109.4 million figure really is a
number so that's where we stand right
now if you move to the next page the
2425 appropriation bills this is a list
of all appropriation bills that are
still alive in either
body and again I'll Focus only on the
general fund impact here because you can
see a number of them have education
trust fund impacts other fund impacts
Etc I'll be ignoring those for the
moment if you go down to the total
Appropriations at the
bottom the general fund impact over the
two years is roughly $138 million so the
two bodies right now have $138 million
requests however there are two items
that I would add to that there is
unfortunately these rows aren't numbered
but if you go
about a little over a third down the
page you can see House Bill 1633 Canabis
legalization and
regulation that has an $8.1 million
liquor fund appropriation but that will
affect general fund Revenue so I would
consider that a general fund
impact
also down near the bottom Senate Bill
476 docc New Hampshire state prison for
men that has a uh General obligation
Bond of $40 million however that comes
at a cost in with uh in terms of debt
service to the general fund of $4.6
million so I would so those two
items total about $12.7 million and I
would add that to the $138 million
appropriation figure that you see here
so collectively there's about 50 $151
million uh general fund impact in terms
requests plus the unknowns you mentioned
the state is in litigation right there's
Surplus uh and revenue fluxes yes and
the like quite a few unknowns as well as
there are bills without Appropriations
right now that uh to which the Senate
could add Appropriations or other house
committees might add Appropriations so
there's there's we're in a state of flux
right now there are some unknowns but
that's the that's the big
picture very good thank you for that any
questions representative walner F
followed by representative
Wier thank you Mr Ripple Mr Ripple could
you remind us what the lapse the actual
lapse was at the end of the last bium
I I will have to take a look at that one
I don't know off the top of my head but
I can get it for you
shortly thank
you representative Wier thank you madam
chair uh April 30th I attended a meeting
of the arpa uh allocation requests and
was interesting to see that the senate
had put in additional requests pending
eligibility review of Sen Bill
406 which is the increase for shelter
rates Senate Bill 311 which is the
Hamstead property uh payment and Senate
Bill 396 the cost associated with
ventilation and exhaustion fans at the
uh Hudson
CTE they seem to think they can fund
them from these funds and I also
questioned only the only members of the
House were myself and the speaker why
there's no house bills also listed
and I was told by the um director of
budget send me the list so some of those
that we think are going to be difficult
I will try to come down to uh especially
most of these are not the biggest one
there was the 2 and A5 million for the
shelter rates and the the Hamstead one
is 54,000 and the the one at uh the CTE
is 67200 these are the other ones are
less than a million so we have bills
that we think we have priority for that
we see a problem with the other side I'm
going to bring them into the budget
director and ask that they be considered
for the uh any excess arpa funds because
we'll be all this year we'll be um
looking at the ones that can't be
constructed before 2026 if there's a
construction thing or some other way if
this is money that just goes to uh an
agency higher or to to expand then that
will be a lot easier to take that money
than for a construction project so I'll
be looking at those I'll be getting
together with Mr Ripple and the other uh
LBA folks to see which ones we really
want and see if there is room in these
uh reallocations of the arpa funds so
thank
you representative tersi thank you madam
chair I just have a quick question for
the chairman wer do you have a estimate
on the arpa funds that are potentially
available for these one time projects so
we know sort of the
pot
um this figure says well the the Gopher
ones um has already 16 million in new
money request the total under the
additional legislative request that
looks like they're looking at
8,842
77799 so yeah they're they're
reallocating all the time we will have
another arpa meeting probably later this
year so some of these things will be
then okay anything further for Mr Ripple
or on this
topic
excellent thank you
again so the thought here is to go bill
by Bill starting in order though there
are two bills we may be able to take up
at the same time but we'll get to that
352 that is
establishing an early detection cancer
screening pilot program for active and
retired
firefighters so this
bill summary of the docket if you want
the full docket please go to nh.gov but
a summary came out of Senate Health and
Human Services 5 to Z Sen Finance 7 to 0
full Senate 24 to0 house Health and
Human Services committee 20 to0 and
through the Full House on a Voice vote
two next I just want to look at the
fiscal note while we're introducing this
particular segment of the work
session so the most recent fiscal note
is dated 32124 is that correct
yes okay not to exceed $5 million over
the periods between 2025 to
2027 okay anything further on the fiscal
note okay all right I understand there
are individuals here who are interested
in speaking so we'll start with that
unless the members have anything they
want to start with
okay who would like to begin Brian
will excellent so if you could just uh
introduce yourselves make sure your
microphones are on there should be a red
light went on and uh we are ready when
you are also for those in the audience
if you'd like some light there is a
switch on the wall there double
switch which would be uh probably
helpful thank you okay Mr real when
you're ready thank you madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Brian will I'm the president
of the professional firefighters of New
Hampshire and I'm a fire captain in the
city of
Portsmouth my name is Dr Michael Hamrock
I'm a primary care and addiction
medicine physician at Stan Elizabeth's
Medical Center in Boston
Massachusetts Hamrock h a m r o c
k and uh Madam Sheriff just um you'd
oblig for a few minutes just to kind of
give a brief overview of of the plan and
and what we're asking um app appreciate
it absolutely great thank so much um
thank you for mentioning the success
that this bill has had along the way
beginning first in the Senate uh and
then onto the house um with no um no
really debate or uh issues um along the
way this is a program that we U came
forward with uh the idea of uh
constructing last session um and members
of the House had requested that we uh
build out the program that is best
suited for firefighters um get access to
subject matter experts and really
identify the testing that needs to be
done um to uh detect cancer early in our
firefighters um just a a quick statistic
75% of the names that are added to the
Fallen Firefighters Memorial out in
Colorado Springs uh are members that
died from occupational cancer um and so
that is the precipice for why we're here
today um to move this program forward
what we're trying to do here is
establish a program uh that would allow
screening comprehensive uh cancer
screening to uh all professional active
and retired firefighters throughout the
state of New Hampshire we want to
compile the data that's necessary to
look at how we drive long-term uh a
long-term program that is purposeful and
impactful for our members um just a a
quick anecdote uh right across the
street right now as we speak at the
holiday in uh our our firefighting
organization uh is actually screening
100 uh members firefighters um that are
that have attended our banial convention
we raised the funding for that uh we
raised about
$175,000 to screen these members this is
how important this program is to us um
we're we're stepping up to initiate this
process and hoping that the state will
uh come forward um with this this amount
of money this $5 million to help screen
everybody in the state um and with that
I would kick it over to Dr Hamrock to
give more a more comprehensive approach
here as to why we chose the test that we
did um and then Madam chair if we would
have a few minutes after just to discuss
a possible change uh to the the bill as
is I would appreciate that thank
you Doctor when you're ready thank you
Brian I I want to thank all the uh
members of division 3 committee for
allowing me to testify today uh as I
introduce myself Dr Michael Hamrock I'm
a primary care and addiction medicine
doc at St Elizabeth's Medical Center in
Boston and I'm here to strongly Advocate
uh for this bill for early detection
screening pilot program for firefighters
in New Hampshire I believe I have a
unique perspective on firefighter health
issues as a former Boston firefighter
and a medical director of the Boston
fire department I currently take care a
lot of firefighters with uh as a primary
care physici and we have a early
detection screening program at my
hospital where we screen uh the early
detection screening test to pick up
early heart disease and cancer and first
respond as then I can tell over the past
two years we saved the lives of 13
firefighters with these early detection
screening tests finding cancer at an
early stage uh I also developed uh
cience of physical exams for
firefighters a template that's used
across the country for Primary Care
Providers I'm also a co-author of a book
called surviving the fire service that
explains the unique risk firefighters
have for health issues and I'm also
a member of the firefighter canc support
network as a as a medical advisory uh
doctor there and I've been uh named the
past four years as and Boston Magazine's
uh top top doct
list but so the reason I'm here you know
really my goal is to have firefighters
across the country get these early
detection screenings I believe it's
going to save the lives of Hampshire
firefighters like we've have in Boston
and we all know now there's a four times
better chance of surviving uh in the
stage one two cancer from these early
detection tests versus stage three and
four cancer uh and we we all know the
the tremendous stress that cancer has on
firefighters in our families and
financial stress as well and I believe
this early detection test will save uh
New Hampshire tax pays money as well by
finding these cancas early the firef
hopefully can stay work and won't go off
on injur a sick leave and won't have to
retire early so everyone benefits from
these tests and I also believe it allows
firefighter to be more safe and
effective on a fire ground ground by
having a healthy
Workforce the other thing about these
tests if you do find a lung nod on a
fire figh with these CAT scans they
automatically have that diagnosis our a
lung nodule so from for the next 30
years or however old the fire fighter is
the fall up Skins are covered by the
insurance company not by the state uh
any anymore because they own that
diagnosis of a lung nodule so it doesn't
have to be uh yearly tested or picked up
by the state uh but the bottom line is
I've lot too many good friends and uh
colleagues from firefighter cancer uh
and and I think a lot of them died
needlessly because we didn't have these
tests available back then and and and
that's really why I'm asking your
support this bill for early detection
screenings we all know firefighting is a
great occupation the sense of
comaraderie the morale the uh you know
tremendous reward of saving people's
lives but because that firefighters pay
a huge price being part of the
firefighter family and and we all know
firefighters come on a job healthy go
through the physical ability test go
through the academy but unfortunately we
see several years after that tremendous
health issues with firefighters
including heart disease and cancer
conditions the National Institute of
occupation safety and health did a study
uh 30 year study completed in 2020 and
and looked at cancer and firefighters
they looked at 30,000 firefighters in
Chicago San Francisco and Philadelphia
and they actually found that the
firefighters have a 9% higher rated of
cancer than the general population and
unfortunately 14% higher rate of dying
from cancer than the general population
uh in Boston we see three cancers every
every month in our firefighters we
average 20 per year and and
unfortunately several members are very
sick right now probably won't make it
through through the year in each case
cost the city over quar million dollars
so we spend over $5 million a year just
in cancer cases alone the fire
department uh so my goal is to have more
early detection so these firefighters uh
if they do get cancer caught in an early
stage and and and very successfully
treated and save the taxpayers in Boston
like myself money as well uh by having
these early detection
tests the World Health Organization uh
came up with a new report uh their
International Agency for cancer research
in the summer of 2023 and they now
reclassify firefighting as a
cancer-causing occupation group one
which is the highest level so you know
right away when you take this job you'll
walk into our professionals there's a
good chance it's going to give you
cancer and get another reason why we
need to do something for the
firefighters and get these early
detection screenings on
board Governor Baker Massachusetts in
2018 passed a a bill um basically stated
that uh firefigher develop cancer it's a
job related injury and they should be
covered uh immediately because of that
and and we had 3005 fighters in
Massachusetts two years prior to that
develop caner kind of instigated uh
pushing up Bill there's also additional
money in the mass fireing cry budget to
screen firefighters with these early
detection screening test as well in
hopes we can prevent firefighters from
getting cancer if they do get it it'll
be successfully
treated so I think the big question is
you know why do firefighters develop
cancer versus maybe other
professions we know when the combustion
of products in our home like these uh
the the chairs we're sitting in today
they all contain flame and
prevent the fire from spreading but we
know when these uh materials combust
they give off dangerous cancer causing
chemicals at the fire foter is inhale
and ingest and absorb into the skin and
cancer develop several years later we
also know smoldering Plastics and syn
synthetics in people's homes give off
poly aromatic hydrocarbons and uh they
give cancer and firefighter as well and
even diesel exhaust hanging around the
firehouse you don't have to be go to
fires every day but it's hanging around
the firehouse with a de exhaust
particles uh gives uh promotes cancer as
well particularly uh kidney cancer and
bladder cancer I give you one example in
one of our firhouse in Boston and J in
the North End the kitchen is right off
the main floor and the apparatus goes in
and out of there blowing the diesel
exhaust right into the kitchen and the
walls are kind of dark in there because
of that and the plates have a have a
dark tens to them because of that and we
had three firefighters in a year and a
half develop kidney cancer most likely
because of that effect and fortunately
we got dies dies exhaust vents in the
fires now to hopefully prevent that from
happening another example is we had
engine 7's house in the Back Bay they
they bought a brand new flat screen TV
uh from one of the local dealers six
months later the TV stopped working it
was in the second floor of the firehouse
where all the firefighters congregate
and they brought it back to the dealer
and he open up the back of it he said
this does not look like the TV I sold it
six months ago there was three inches of
diesel exhaust particle in the back of
the TV this is what the TV absorbed you
know for six months can you imagine what
the firefighters are doing working in
that firehouse and really exposed to
these dangerous
chemicals the other big risk factor of a
cancer in firefight is it's a p fast
chemicals you might have heard about
recently poly floral alkal substances
that are in the firefighters gear
they're in the the form that the
firefighters use and they're in the
firehouse dust because of the leak off
from the gear and it's a huge risk
factor for cancer
now so it's all these risk factors that
put firefi risk uh for cancer and all
these chemicals these dangerous
chemicals the fers in the
heel into the mouth into the lungs they
ingest through the mouth into the
stomach and they also absorb through the
skin and all these chemicals make their
way into the bloodstream of the
firefighters uh cause cell mutation cell
damage and many years later the cancer
develops into firefighters and that's
the that's the true mechanism of cancer
and firefighters and can you imagine
today if there was a fire tonight in
conquer Massachusetts and
uh maybe some of the firefighters
checked down to the TD gu on Boston City
Bruns on Friday if people sitting beside
those firefighters you can still smell
tra of smoke coming from their body this
is from a fire uh three and a half days
previously and that's all these toxic
chemicals making the way out to the
firefighters pors and uh we see this a
lot in firefighters and after every big
fire we know they're going to uh smell
like that for several days after each
fire no matter how many showers they
take
so when you think about these risk
factors fir Fighters have and what type
of cances are fir fighter getting that
kind of really goes into why we needed
screenings particular uh screenings for
firefighters that detect these cancers
that firefighters getting if you think
about the mechanism we just talked about
the inhalation uh the absorption uh and
the direct
exposure we see a lot of respiratory
tract Cancers and firefighters when
these uh chem chemicals come in dig T of
cancers esophagus colon stomach and we
also see a lot of neurogen urogenital
cancers from the uh way to cancer comes
in the chemicals come in but also the
way to eliminate through the body kidney
cancer bladder cancer testicular cancer
ovarian cancer and female fir Fighters
is
huge and we also see skin cancers just
from direct exposure and we see blood
cancers and Fir Fighters Leukemia and
Lymphoma and multim Myoma as
well one big concern we see now is as
more woman firefighters come on the job
we getting better studies on women
firefighters have particular high risk
certain cancers particular their thyroid
Harkins lymphoma breast cancer and
uterine cancer so it's really
significant problem and these past
chemicals are also intro inter
interfering with their reproductive
system and we're seeing a lot of uh
infertility and female Firs because of
that and also some uh miscarriages
unfortunately some birth effects in
their children which is awful thing to
see another good reason why we need
these early early detection
screenings so these P fast chemicals
that I talked about you know they're in
the firefighter the three Linings of the
firefighters bunker gear so the typical
fire or even just hanging around the
fire house with the gear you know
through whether it be sunlight water
exposure or heat or just wear and tear
these PE fast chemicals come off the
firefighters gear uh the firefighters
inhale them and adjust them as well C up
on a firefighter dust floor and it's
been many studies and firefighters now
looking at uh the blood after a fire or
even a week or so after uh being in the
firehouse the blood levels and
firefighters are much higher than the
general population of this past chemical
because of their exposures to the bunker
gear that they're actually wearing which
uh to me is
unacceptable and and we know these uh P
fast chemicals are causing testicular
kidney Cancers and firefighters and and
there's also some new studies showing
we're also seeing cancer on the younger
firefighters too was a general TR across
the country for the general public but
we see them more and younger
firefighters uh as
well because of all this I think the
fire service has been pretty proactive
about U making firefighters more aware
of that be much more careful on the fire
ground makeing sure you're wearing your
uh breathing apparatus uh make sure your
gears on properly we have firefighters
take a shower immediately after uh
fighting a fire
uh we wash the gear immediately after
fires uh we get a vigorous workout 24
hours after a fire to get rid of some of
these toxins through the skin as well uh
but despite that we see still seeing
some issues and that's why we need these
early detection screening programs and
we need to be much more proactive with
these with these screening programs I
difference so I'm convinced these
screenings do stabiliz uh and did not
meant to replace the good physical exam
it's a complimentary test an addition to
the physical exam uh the problem I see
with the the typical screenings that we
all get from the US preventive task
force uh it's meant for the general
public but the firefights need
additional screening because of those
RIS that I mentioned so the typical
screening physical exam is not enough of
firefighters actually you're missing
about 70% of cancers and firefighters
with the traditional screening test that
uh we have been doing uh we know the
lung uh scans actually reduce cancer by
20 reduceed death by 20% now which is
pretty remarkable these lung
scans so again I push for advocating
these screening tests for Fighters with
these high-risk cancers the respirat
tract the gener urinary tract uh the
blood cancers and the skin cancers and
the uh digestive
cancers so one of the tests we're
talking about is this multi-cancer early
detection blood test a gallery company
makes it it can detect up 50 different
types of cancer in one blood draw
and uh you know it's
pretty pretty unique technology where
all our cancer cells leak DNA in the
bloodstream but these tests can detect
actually cancer cells a special chemical
on the cancer cell and that in the DNA
that they can actually pick up and
actually track back what organ it came
from so they're pretty remarkable test
and in 15,000 firefighters across the
country have' already had these tests
done and we found a lot of early Cancers
and successfully treated and it has
saved lives uh you know also where I
work Boston we have Dana FAA Cancer
Institute masteral hospital is using
these early detection blood tests as
well uh in the early detection blood
screening program and these are two
nationally recognized uh cancer centers
in the in the
country so I believe these tests are
helpful to fill the Gap in the
screenings that we do not currently have
for our
firefighters other test that I talked
about earlier chest CAT scans and
firefighters because of the issues bre
in these chemicals and affecting their
respiratory system digestive cancers
early age colonoscopies in 5 foots I
like to start at age 40 I believe
abdominal ultrasounds will help as well
looking at certain organs that may be
impacted by
cancers and the eurogen to cancers I
believe female firefighters should get
early age mammograms and pelvic
ultrasounds early uh and and male
firefighter should get testicular
ultrasounds as
well and uh that delivery blood test
will help uh that multi-cancer early
detection blood test will help all these
cancers as well as the blood cancers
that fire fighs are
getting one example of lung skin in
Boston we had 218 firefighters go
through the test 30% actually had lung
nodules that's almost one out every
three firefighters and these lung NOS uh
could predispose them to developing a
cancer so they have to be follow very
closely by their primary dock in a lung
specialist as well Manchester uh New
Hampshire firefighter has went through a
similar screening test and 16 of their
120 members actually had lung nodules
that are going to be followed closely we
had one firefight in Boston last year
had two lung nodules they were they were
fairly large in size they end up being
cancerous he had his lung reector and
unfortunately he's doing well and and
disease so again just these lung scans
don't just show the lungs though we've
seen a lot of uh esophageal thickening
that could be uh cancer of esophagus as
well we found a lot of anisms on our
firefighters with these lung scans uh
and and there's a lot of kidney lesions
and liver lesions we found with these
lung skins as well and it has been very
impactful so so I just want to summarize
you know what we just talked about and
it is the fire ground and the fire host
that are putting firef at risk for
cancer we now know the World Health
Organization classifies uh firefighter
as a group one cancer causing occupation
and and we know the high-risk uh organs
that are involved in the fire service
now as well and I believe we need
additional screening test beyond what
the physical uh typical physical that
getting so I am very convinced that
these fire these screening tests will
save the lives New Hampshire
firefighters it's going to save the
taxpayers in New Hampshire money from
injury disability and overtime cost as
well and it hopefully eliminate the
tremendous stress that firefighters
families go through
the other think is going to help boost
recruiting if the state has a program in
place it's going to screen firefighters
for a disease that the we know the
occupation is going to cause I think
it's a huge huge boost for recruiting so
and thank you very much for having me
present today and uh talking about
me thank you very much for all that uh
very well detailed information and
obviously your background uh you know
know about these things very thoroughly
so thank you very much and I'm sorry to
hear about all the sufferings that
people who dedicate their lives to
protecting the public have to
undergo these things are not taken
lightly here thank
you representative wer uh thank you Dr
Hamrock you might have this
information how expensive is it to do a
blood test for past that
specifically so the past you know not
every lab does these fast blood testing
you know he's basically looking for this
chemical that the firef is exposed to uh
I don't know if in University of Arizona
is doing a huge study now on fireflies
across the country with these tests uh
but I suspect they go about $200 but the
test itself means that you're exposed to
the chemical you know it doesn't say you
have cancer it just shows that you
exposed to this chemical it's the early
cancer detection test that's uh more
effective that will determine is this
firefighter have uh potential cancer in
the body
well I'm I'm thinking of that for a
wider thing for the whole state because
we're going to spend a lot of money on
on water treatment and I wonder how much
we already all of us have been exposed
before we spend a lot of money on water
treatment so I wonder how expensive that
test would be the P fast material is
also in in paper products and things
that when you buy from stores it's it's
it's everywhere but it's firi are much
highly exposed to
it okay representative Lon followed by
by representative priest um thank you
madam chair and thank you doctor for
being here for this um I'm actually on
the Health and Human Services committee
and I had a lot of questions I had to
ask to other people since I know that
you were busy um seeing patients that
day um and Madam chair if you'd indulge
me with a few questions um my first is
um about this Gallery test um why this
test and what's the cost per
test the cost per test I believe is
about $900 for the general public I know
they have a pro program for the service
I believe they're about
$650 thank you that's helpful do you
know the sensitivity and specificity of
this
see sorry and for those of us who
haven't been in the diagnostic spacer in
medical school that's how many um false
negatives so the literature that I see
from uh the company is still you know
they're looking at much more uh
screening tests they really bringing ac
across this country as well as Europe
but uh the literature shows that
uh they have false positive test uh less
than 1% spec specificity that's
percentage of true negatives is greater
than 99% that's the literature okay
thank you um and do you know how many of
the detected cancers have no treatment
at the stage of diagnos diagnosis and if
there's any clinical history for those
cancers at stage one or stage two if
they're not commonly found well every
every Cancer no matter what stage it has
is Treatment available uh but obviously
you want to find cancer at stage one and
two uh the literature I hear from the
blood testing company about 50% of the
cancer they find are in stage one and
two um sorry you said that every cancer
has treatments available correct great
okay um thank you I was not aware of
that fact I mean um you go to Dana FAA
today with any typ of cancer you're
going to get treatment for it oh those
with tests thank you um and then do you
know um what happens if the manufacturer
changes this test since it's still in
clinical trials or if they cease to make
this test available before this pilot
program is
done what I understand they're learning
from every every every test that they do
they they're learning about it and
hopefully uh make it more sensitive down
the road uh but again you know 15,5
across the country been through this
test and it's used uh regularly at Daya
fa can Institute in Mass General
Hospital as well because they have a
high faith in this test um thank you do
you know if those 15,000 um firefighters
were part of the clinical trials or if
it's done in a different program they're
currently enrolling 35,000 people in
order to test this to see about the
validity and effectiveness of this test
it's in its own study with the fire
service uh not they not in that
population there also a test under away
with Medicare patients uh 50,000
patients are enrolled in it right now um
would it be a Poss possible for to have
instead of paying for this in the state
for $600 a test to instead collaborate
um to have New Hampshire firefighters
included in a clinical trial for this
because it probably could reach to other
states as well and not have the
taxpayers pay for an investigational
test would that be a possibility if we
were to remove this multi-cancer early
early detection blood test from this
bill and have um and pursue this through
clinical trials which the company should
be able to support instead of the
taxpayers supporting yet oh you number
one I'm not going to speak to New
Hampshire firefighters or or the or the
company which I don't work for have any
stake in at all and if I just have one
last question and then my question would
be um if you know why Dana Farber and
Mass General are not participating in
the clinical trial for
this I don't know what the what trials
are actually participating in they're
actually putting a thousand uh veterans
uh through a program at Dana faan now
with his early detection cancer test
thank you I'm sorry for getting so deep
in the weeds I did a lot of diagnostic
approvals and bringing them to Market
thank you thank you representative
priest followed by representative tersi
thank you for taking my question and
thank you for being here and for
representing New Hampshire's
firefighters do you have the number of
how many
firefighters um have died of
cancer in the past and have been
diagnosed with cancer now I don't know
what happen National number I can say in
Boston we had 195 Fighters over the past
23 years ding from cancer then I'll ask
the representative from new do you have
any numbers of the cases in New
Hampshire of
firefighters having being diagnosed of
cancer on their jobs or having died of
cancer in the
past um thank for your question
representative I do not I'm gonna cut to
the chase I do not have those hard
numbers what I can tell you um is over
the last well I
have about eight to 10 names here that
over the last uh 10 years have died from
occupational cancer in the state of New
Hampshire Alone um and we we have
someone here uh that's behind us that
has a very personal story um that he's
willing to share with you all um as to
how this impacts you know one
firefighter death how this impact
somebody in New Hampshire can I follow
up please follow up thank you um
and this question is for both of you um
you you Doctor you made a mention that
um monies could be saved by early
Detention of cancer do you have a kind
of case study of how much money was
saved by uh detecting cancer at stage
one and stage two and how much cost
would be for the disability cost and and
the ongoing Medical C
treatments the literature that I read
has uh finding cancer stage one and two
half thank you representative tersi
thank you very much Madam chair I want
to thank you so much for taking the time
and coming up here to um share your
knowledge with us on this very important
issue um I do want to um I know we've
all received some information that there
actually is some changes requested to
the bill so in the consideration of time
maybe we can have U Mr real go down what
those changes
are yes Mr R you have proposed a very
clear Amendment uh that you would like
to suggest and I certainly appreciate
the way you have formatted it to make it
Crystal what you're looking for if you
could take us through that at this time
sure thank you for the opportunity um as
Dr Hamrock mentioned uh the the World
Health Organization says that uh the the
cost for early detection cancer
diagnosis uh is two to four times uh a
cost savings to that of a late St stage
diagnosis um so when we when we talk
about costs there is a cost impact here
to the state of New Hampshire it's not
only lives uh potentially saved um but
it is a true fiscal cost uh savings to
to uh early detection programs um so we
are not asking for a change to the
overall fiscal note of this bill which
is $5 million what we have requested is
uh two minor changes one would be to
remove the skin cancer screening portion
uh the reason for that is we um
understand that the $5 million is a
significant cost um and we're trying to
be as fiscally uh prudent as possible
with this we know that our members uh
have access to uh Dermatology exams
through their uh insurance companies as
it stands today so um if I were to go to
my PCP I could um tell them you know I
want to get a skin cancer screening um
he may or may not ask why um but then I
would get a referral um to get that
screening that doesn't happen with some
of these other tests so what we're
wanting to ensure is that we're spending
State funds as responsibly as possible
so we would ask for the removal of that
piece and we would take it upon
ourselves to educate our members to get
out and get these screenings um the
second piece would be the removal of the
$1300 cap per person um the only reason
for that is to uh adjust for inflation
um I had a good conversation with a
couple folks on this committee uh about
the importance of that some of the tests
that we've looked at um we base this
$1,300 number on current costs as this
thing is progressed we know that uh the
cost of uh one of the tests has gone up
about $100 so we don't want to hamstring
um our members we want them to have
access to every portion of the test um
and we do believe that there would still
be enough money within that $5 million
to get that done um and then as is
written in here any funds that are not
expent would then go back to the state
so we would um we would request those
two minor changes from this
committee representative tar
thank you very much I just have one um
quick question based on your requested
Amendment which I believe we've already
submitted um for drafting um do you feel
if we lift the cap that you'll still be
able to reach all of the um firefighters
that you hope to reach with that $5
million ultimate uh ceiling yes thank
you for your question representative I I
believe that to be true um the reason
for that is um
unfortunately is no matter how much we
educate our members and push them into
this not everyone's going to probably
get the screening that's just by the
nature of uh all of us right is a lot of
us probably uh in this room may not even
have a primary care position
unfortunately so um it's hard to uh get
folks to do that this money um would
account for if every firefighter in the
state got all portions of the screening
as I mentioned earlier across the street
right now um we have 100 firefighters
that are already getting the blood test
and the ultrasound diagnostic they would
not then need to repeat those tests
should this bill passed um so there we
would come in um I have a strong belief
we would come in under wait under the
five million thank you very much for
that clarification that's
valuable with regards to the
cap um you and I discussed this in
section Roman 6 of the bill still the
number 1300 is there and not your
intention to take that
out correct thank you um yes the reason
we left that piece in there was simply
if someone was to seek reimbursement if
they went off and got uh any portion of
these tests or all portions of these
tests on their own we wanted some uh
ability for them to come and seek for
reimbursement uh but we wanted that to
be within reason we didn't want someone
to go out uh and get these these tests
done at
$110,000 and then come seek
reimbursement for $110,000 when the
tests are available for less expensive
than that so we just want to as a
safeguard for the state to make sure
that we're we're being reasonable with
our
reimbursements okay and then with regard
to section Roman five where you do take
out the cap is it your thought that I
mean could you say that most will exceed
1300 or most will not or it's to hard to
tell or there's a a mixture of who would
exceed and who wouldn't what is your
thought there so that's a that's a great
question thank you uh I think it would
be part of it would be dependent on the
other piece the skin cancer screening um
I'll give you for instance um we had uh
a member who just recently got their
skin cancer screening and their
insurance covered it however the cost of
that test alone was just shy of $1,000
doll so if that wasn't removed and a
member went and got their skin cancer
screening and the state paid $1,000
towards it they would only then have
$300 left to cover what is
about $1,500 in testing um so they would
more more than likely exceed that now if
we removed the skin cancer screening
piece I believe the $1,300 will be close
certainly I believe that if this program
went out through the state's bidding
process
um that there would be vendors that
would be able to come in at under say
$2,000 per test somewhere around
there okay thank you and represent ters
you said you're going to have his
suggested Amendment exactly as he
described it drafted it's already been
drafted I believe Mr Ripple has it okay
I have two versions of that Amendment
one for representative tersi and a
slightly different version for
representative wer that changes the 1300
to 1400 um but as as I look at this now
it changes the 1300 in Roman 5 but not
in Roman 6 so if you were to adopt
representative wier's Amendment we
probably want to make that change as
well um but I can hand out one or both
of those amendments now whichever you'd
prefer Mr will thank you um and um thank
you representative wer for having a
phone conversation with me the other day
and uh it was you were you were gracious
enough to give me some time to express
what we were looking to do I may have
missed spoke or misled you to believe
that we were at the $1,400 range uh My
Hope was that we could just remove that
cap um and let the the the process play
out knowing that there will be um a
state bitting process that we'll keep
we'll drive the cost of these down as
low as we can as well thank you if the
sponsors are okay I don't see a problem
with the
distribution at this point no votes
today as I mentioned but something for
us to consider as we go forward that's
uh what we're charged with today
representative Lyon followed by
representative priest um yes Madam chair
I had an amendment that was drafted in
the Health and Human Services committee
that we didn't offer because we simply
ran out of time and so I can have that
printed to distribute that removed the
multi-cancer blood screening section um
and gave a little bit more flexibility
in the Contracting so if that's helpful
I can have that printed and distributed
as well uh that's fine and if you could
send it to us once it's drafted that
would be helpful but you're saying that
your proposed
amendment suggests that we remove the
blood
testing the blood test from uh section
Roman a Roman one lowercase
a um yes it actually it removes all of
section B um because the specificity on
the diagnostic ultrasound I don't think
is NE necessity in how they contract it
because it sounds that those people who
are doing it are already well versed in
what's needed um and this may bind their
ability to do what they need to do
should things change um we actually had
I had had that drafted we had to act by
noon and I received it at 11:40 which is
why the committee didn't adopt it and
why the committee said that this was
important and that's why we moved 20 to
zero to pass this along even though the
policy side was not fully
settled representative walner yes I I
would like to have um for Dr hanr Rock
to maybe speak to even though we don't
have the amendment in front of us speak
to what that Amendment would mean um for
firefighters thank
you now I'm a big fan of of the multic
cancer earlyer detection test because as
I mentioned previously the unique risk
of fire5 is half of cancer and all these
organ systems respiratory system
gastrointestinal genital urinary uh skin
and blood cancers that uh are typical
screening tests Miss 70% of those
cancers are typical physical exam that
firefighters get and and that's why I
believe these multic cancer early
detection tests are necessary for these
high-risk uh this high-risk occupation
and I'm convinced it will save lives so
necessary representative
priest thank you um uh Madam chairman
and I have a question for representative
Lan what was the purpose and the reason
behind removing this multi- blood test
um thank you that's actually a very good
question so this blood test Gallery is
made by or this blood test Grail is made
by a company called Gallery um it had
been spun off from a company then it was
reacquired recently both the United
States and the European Union raised
Anti-Trust concerns so this company that
was acquired for 10 billion and has now
been written down to I believe a three
billion doll company is being forcibly
spun off or launched an IPO the
challenge here is that their annual
revenues are about 100 million a year
while their operating cost their burn
rate is 800 million a year given that
they do not yet have FDA approval and
this is done as a Clea lab test so this
is a specialty test at approved labs and
it's very much of a one-off test at this
point as far as when you look at both
Regulatory and reimbursement because
this does not have an approval as a
quote unquote FDA approved test but is
available to the clear process there's a
huge amount of uncertainty as to what
the cost of regulatory approval would be
and whether or not the company would be
able to be viable as an ongoing company
by the time that this pilot program
exists um given the Dynamics of the
market given the uncertainty around the
diagnostic space given the challenge
other competitors in the space have had
in order to bring a mar a a product like
this to Market even after bringing other
novel Diagnostics to Market I'm highly
concerned that that roll out will not be
successful
and by naming a test that may not
actually be available because the
company may not be functional it
absolutely hamstrings what the state
would be doing it would give false hope
to the firefighters and it also would
take away from the fact that we need to
be doing these lung CT SC SC um
screenings we need to be doing these
ultrasound screenings I think that we
should focus on those that we know will
be available through this time period
and going forward as opposed to one that
may simply be a victim of the Capital
markets and may not not actually be
available in the future or even for the
length of this pilot
program thank you and I have a follow-up
question to uh the doctor
Hamrock
um you mentioned that this this bill
just provides the option for
firefighters to to be screened and to
take the early test to detect cancer and
that that's correct cor right how many
firefighters um do you estimate will be
participating and will'll be doing this
voluntarily my goal would have everyone
eligible to actually participate in this
test because I I've seen it be very very
effective and I can understand there
rep's concern with the business aspect
of it but I can tell the science behind
it uh is very conclusive that it is an
effective test and and it's why Folks At
The Dana fire Mass General are using
this test now and uh you know it's been
vetted by their teams as well and they
speak very highly of this test so I my
goal to have everyone eligible to take
this test in New Hampshire fire service
retirees and active members because I
think we're going to find early disease
that's going to be treatable and
hopefully these firefighters who have it
uh will be able to stay working and the
retired firefighters can enjoy the
retirement years even further because of
uh the results of this
test thank you so just to in project on
the fiscal note representative under the
methodology it does State there are
3,626 individuals that would be
considered
eligible if that's
helpful yes Mr re thank you man chair um
I would just like to draw attention to a
couple items here because I don't I want
to make sure that everyone's got factual
information um this nowhere in this bill
does it identify who a specific vendor
is to provide any of these tests this
will go through the state's bidding
process just as anything else does um I
appreciate uh representative lon's
concerns um but if they are not if if
the company that she's referring to is
not a solvent company that wants to bid
on this process others have the
opportunity to do so whether it's
Dartmouth Hitchcock or it's Dana Farber
or whoever else wants to provide the
test um that has the capabilities to do
so they are eligible to bid on it
secondly um I would like to draw
attention to the fact that this has
already been vetted by two policy
committees um we're I would hope that
we're just discussing the financial
aspect of this which is why we were
bringing forward some ideas to um keep
track of uh the finances and make sure
that we were responsible in our
presentation to you all um I I was a
part of th those those conversations
with you all in the policy committee um
and this was uh we've seen positive
votes across the board for this so thank
you okay thank you uh representative
Leon um thank you um I would appreciate
any followup with any other companies
that offer these diagnostic tests
because I as far as I'm aware the one
that you're speaking of has is far more
advanced than anything else available
and I'm not sure that there's anything
else would be available to backfill so
I'd like that information and second um
I do challenge the the the statement
that it was fully vetted by our policy
committee um as you were aware I I'm
very glad that I'm able to speak to the
doctor today I was asking lay people
specific diagnostic questions um and we
still haven't gotten into all the
details on the Diagnostics so thank
you just what could be a simple question
but in and I realize others are here to
testify and we will hear you um in your
amendment in the amendment you propose
and also in the bill so it uses the word
and so these tests you know in in
section Roman 1 lowercase a a blood test
an ultrasound of vital
organs and a lung CT if indicated is
that right or should it say or so my
apologies for that I I guess my
presentation to you wasn't as clear as
we thought but that was just because we
removed and a skin cancer screening we
just had to add the word and in uh to
make it grammatically correct and that's
why it's in bold there well understood
but in the amendment proposed by
representative lki on line five and is
still
there where it says and day long CT yes
yep that's accurate because um because
we had it and was not there prior it
said uh a an ultrasound of vital organs
comma a lung CTF indicated comma and a
cancer screening because we crossed out
and a cancer screen we just had to move
the and to the other part of the
sentence gotcha but my question is all
of these tests they're all required for
the screening or can you just have a
blood test and not the ultrasound or the
lung CT so all members would be offered
all components of the test and they
could either get all of them or for me
for instance I just had my blood draw
and my ultrasound this morning uh I
would primarily be looking to just get
the lung CT so they would be offered all
components of it they may not get all
components of
it
okay all right anything further for
these
individuals okay thank you both very
much anything further from you all right
thank you
thanks I know we have others um in
however order you'd like to come forward
okay if you could just state your name
naturally for the record and perhaps
spell it and uh make sure your mic is on
what you have welcome sure thank you uh
my name is Christopher Wyman I'm a
lieutenant with the mar Mac New
Hampshire Fire Department um and I'm
just here to talk briefly about one
aspect that you guys asked about was um
what's the impact on New Hampshire
firefighters um I'm a 32-year member of
the New Hampshire fire service I've been
a State Fire Marshal as well as a local
firefighter now serving in marac um my
wife at the same time was a 26- year
member of the New Hampshire fire service
both a marac firefighter and retired as
a Nashville firefighter my wife uh
developed occupational lung cancer uh in
January of 2023 and in November of 2023
she passed away from that from that
occupational related cancer so
her diag tic team if that's what you
want to call it or her oncologists we
like to call them the Dream Team uh both
from Mass General and from Dana Farber
uh she had some amazing oncologists that
treated her through every step of her
process um even though when she was
originally diagnosed she was diagnosed
with and I'm always going to screw up
the name of it Andino carcinoma non-s
small lung cancer that was aggressive in
nature
um by the time she was diagnosed even
though as a firefighter she had annual
physicals being a member of the nashille
fire department being a firefighter or
Hazmat Tech and a member of the dive
team she had to go through annual
physicals annual pulmonary function
tests annual chest x-rays uh all all
those all those required physicals that
the fire department had to do even
though she went through all of those um
some of these diagnostic tests that we
talking about were not part of those
physicals um and unfortunately the
physicals never detected early on her
cancer uh so like I said by the time uh
she was diagnosed uh and we got through
all the testing that went through that
diagnosis she was diagnosed stage four
with mestic cancer to her bones uh she
did receive treatment she did receive
chemotherapy she did receive radiation
um but unfortunately the idea behind
those treatments were for prolonging
life not for curing uh and unfortunately
like I said 11 and a half months after
diagnosis she she succumbed to that
disease and again the city of nashille
and the nashille fire department um
through the workers comp process
determined that her cancer was causally
related to her duties As A Firefighter
for the city of nsha so if you're
looking for its impact from New
Hampshire I know that was asked I can
only speak to the one but for something
like this one one's too many at least in
my brain um if we can take and curve
this I know we can't cure it I know we
can't stop it but if we can take the
burden off the firefighters if we can
take the burden off the families um the
financial burden that goes along with it
um I can tell you you know I had good
medical insurance that covered my wife's
my wife's treatments uh but at the same
time there's a there's a financial
impact that goes that goes with all of
that between co-pays prescriptions you
know stuff that you know and I'm my
wife's been gone almost 6 months now and
I still get bills from the from Mass
General and from Dana Farber and all
that stuff that you know are parts that
insurance does not cover that I'm still
dealing with today so again just one
just one story of its of the impact of
cancer and firefighters like I said
being a member for 32 years I mean it's
a card that we deal in our hands um it's
hope it's one we hope we never see um
I've had friends Steve McKenna from
Salem Fire uh Mike Clark from Handover
fire uh and others that have surpassed
or have passed from cancer as being
firefighters uh so you know you always
you see it you never hope it happens to
you or it lands to you close enough but
like I said unfortunately it does happen
in New Hampshire New Hampshire's not um
avoidance of it so thank you well thank
you for your testimony and I'm very
sorry to hear about the loss of your
wife I feel that I speak on behalf of
the entire community of miramac as well
as division 3 so know that um that means
a lot to us what she gave and what you
have undergone as a supporting spouse
thank you representative Mo any
questions for a officer or firefighter
much
next okay nobody else to speak on Senate
Bill 35
two all
right okay so we have uh multiple
amendments to and it looks like a third
one
coming uh to
consider uh with a vote on Friday so um
I would say we we think about that
unless anybody has any further Thoughts
with regards to these amendments and um
we
can move to the next bill but that was
incredible amount of helpful and
this
okay we move then to Senate Bill
355 that's an act relative to newborn
screening for cylo virus otherwise known
fiscal note I'm looking
at is dated March 5th is that the most
recent I believe you have one that I
handed out separately that's dated today
although the fiscal impact is the same
there isn't one um although I will note
that in conversations with the
department they believe they'll need 20%
of a full-time equivalent position to
carry out the terms of this bill uh
however our stance as an office is that
if a new position isn't actually going
to be filled we treat that as a no
fiscal impact and I think the
unlikelihood of filling a position for
20% of the time is such that this is
essentially a no fiscal impact
bill so a no fiscal impact Bill thank
you for that Mr
Ripple
um on Senate Bill
355 and you'll notice to reflect that it
is not on the appropriation
bills list that we received today is a
triple confirmation of no fiscal impact
anyone here to discuss Senate Bill 355
at this
point if you could just introduce
yourselves naturally make sure your
microphones are fully on that would be
appreciated thank you for being
here good morning my name is Abby Rogers
I'm the legislative L for the division
of Public Health
Services good morning I'm Courtney Keane
I'm with public health and I have direct
oversight of the newborn hearings
program thank you both thanks uh thank
you for allowing us to um provide some
comments on the bill I just wanted to
share that the bill as just a little
history if I could as the bill that was
introduced in the senate had a lot of
technical defects um the intent of the
sponsor was to um have some newborn
screening coverage for cytomegalo virus
which I can get Courtney is really the
expert in that but I can give you some
information that it's one of the most
common infectious causes of birth
defects in the United States with about
one and 200 babies born with congenital
CMV it's um congenital CMV is passed
from Mom to baby um one out of five
babies with congenital CMV have symptoms
of long-term health problems such as
hearing loss um and that can progress
from mild to severe during the first two
years of life which is a critical part
uh area for learn language learning so I
think the intent of the sponsor was to
have some awareness around CMV for
newborn screening um and I can let
Courtney fill you in on that process but
originally in the bill it would have put
uh the screen for CMV under the newborn
screening program which is under RSA
13210 Dasa so CMV is not recommended at
the federal level yet for it to be
included in uh the Rus which was the
recommended uniform screening panel Rec
recommended by Hera so the state program
uh when there is a federal
recommendation then we'll consider those
for adoption to the state program and
that is currently not recommended uh we
worked with Senator inis to try to um
address some of the technical issues in
the bill as introduced and came up with
a what we thought was a great compromise
for the Department to help with
awareness for Education around CMV
through the newborn screening program
yet not adopting it officially um and
also reporting on some screenings that
are being done uh voluntarily by a few
New Hampshire hospitals um after a baby
has failed a couple of screening uh
newborn screening hearing tests uh and
we would include that information in uh
a report to HHS over site that amended
version of the bill came to the house
and we had estimated uh the department
after completing a fiscal note um had
there was no fiscal impact to the
department for the version that passed
um through the Senate and came to the
policy committee so what the bill as you
see it now was amended on the floor um
to add uh the um requirement that the
department would um amend its rule to
require um individuals um conducting
newborn hearings screeing and diagnostic
hearing evaluations um in hospitals uh
or or other facilities to report uh to
the department if the final hearing
screening um was not a pass and if if
there was a CMV test so that's kind of
level set where we are with the bill now
so as Mr Ripple indicated um the
department uh looked at our um what this
might cost to to us and realized that
there would be maybe a point2 FD
required which we estimated to be about
26,000 a year annually um to carry out
the provisions of the bill as passed on
the floor and Courtney can weigh in on
anything she'd like to contribute as
well um the point to FTE which is based
on the amendment um is there to help
with amending the rules which is the
collection of CM CMV results for those
infants who did not pass their second
hearing screening at the hospital
provide hospital and provider education
on CMV testing um
to uh the newborn hearing screening
program data system has the capacity to
collect CMV however Education and
Training will need to be provided to the
hospitals and staff for timely and
accurate data
collection um the position will also be
responsible for reporting so the
oversight committee and then without the
funding the department does not have the
adequate Staffing capacity to make these
new um recommendations based on the
amendment
so a bill to amend a
rule yeah okay uh anyone have any
questions for
these two
witnesses representative Leon um thank
you madam chair and thank you both for
working with me through this whole
process um as adopted on the floor it
actually doesn't have the um it doesn't
specifically call out the education and
the reporting to oversight but you see
that as a direct function of putting
this in to rules that those would
naturally
flow okay that's a yes yes sorry yeah so
part of the education providers they
need to know how to test so we're just
there to provide the support to the
hospitals on what the best Protocols are
thank you yes and if I could add in
working with Senator inis on um the
amendment that passed the Senate he well
the intent was to really have some um
education um and under the new the
newborn screening hearing program um
maybe Courtney could talk about Eddie a
little bit and and what they do and and
how they were planning to look at this
more specifically and kind of flush out
some of the spe spe specifics before
maybe we got to um requiring um
hospitals to report to the department
yeah so currently there are four
hospitals that have adopted on their own
to screen for CMV after the infant does
not pass its second hearing screening
these hospitals do it through urine or
saliva which is the be best method for
um the other hospitals as a standard of
care screen all infants for hearing loss
and if referred they're supposed to go
to an audiologist with their box of risk
factors right so if a baby is screened
at a hospital they would have and had a
CMV test it would be sent to an
audiologist with they were screened for
CMV because it's a different protocol
and I believe there's someone here that
can speak better um than I can on that
um but that is the process right now for
babies who have a hearing screening for
those hospitals that do this screening
they follow up with a CMV test those
other hospitals do a hearing screening
and then send to audiologists for
Diagnostic testing and forther
infant representative Lon followed by
representative walner um thank you do
you know if the time it takes to see an
audiologist is within the diagnostic
window for congenital CMV
infections so you're supposed to screen
an infant for CMV within the first 21
days of life to to determine if it's
congenital infants in New Hampshire are
seen by a diagnostic or an audiologist
around six months of
age thank you that's very helpful
representative
walner thank you could you go over again
um the Staffing what was did I hear that
it was 0.2 yep so 20 % of a
staff and what was the cost of that
26,000
annually for 20% of of a staff
person could I
ask follow up how would you go about
would you actually hire someone
for 20% of a full-time position or would
you wrap this in into another position
that you already have and if so how is
that position funded so I would wrap
this into a position that is already um
that we already have so we get funding
from the CDC and hersa for hearing
screening um so I would leverage that
position to help with the CMV education
data follow up so if if you already have
the position and you already have the
funding there would be no need for an
appropriation at this point I apologize
I would post a position it is so we have
funding and I would allocate funds
through the grant that we have to help
so this would be a combined point so it
would be half of a position a part-time
position to do this work within the
hearing screening program so it would
okay thank you both very
much I try to give a little summary of
the Bill's background so this bill came
out of Senate Health and Human Services
5 to nothing uh then the full Senate by
a Voice vote went to house Health and
Human Services and came out 10 to 10
without a recommendation but after a
floor
Amendment which I see was uh sponsored
by representative Lon it then came out
of the Full House ought to pass with
okay represent
priest thank you madam chairman I just
have a question a clarification question
for one of you please Courtney if you
could join us again
um it was mentioned that you would be
needing uh a staff member that this bill
would cause you to have 20% of a staff
person's time and then I heard 50% staff
I I'm I'm not clear on what's going on
thank you yeah
so my goal would be to so create a
part-time position use 20% of this
funding and match it with 30% of my CDC
you okay yes absolutely step right up
and make sure your microphone is on
please in your
name thank you madam chair my name is
Ben Bradley I'm the vice president of
state government relations for the New
Hampshire Hospital
Association um I appreciate the
testimony or commentary from the
Department of Health and Human Services
on this
bill um we too supported uh the bill
coming out of the Senate with the
language that was proposed there working
with Senator inis uh our members do have
concerns about the direction this bill
has gone uh since the floor amendment in
the house with uh mandating a CMV
screening after a failed hearing test um
particularly because the medical
literature uh does not support that
recommendation um
and
um uh the recommendation for automatic
hearings excuse me automatic CMV
screening after a failed hearing
the American Academy of Pediatrics um is
what we would reference and they too do
not um share the suggested mandate for a
CMV
screening um if I might say we do feel
that this is a really important issue um
it does affect a number of newborns uh
many of our hospitals as pointed out
well I would say um as referenced by the
department four of our hospitals um
members do screen for CMV um and use
their medical judgment as to when to
recommend that um after a failed hearing
screening others do not um have that
policy um but I think this is evolving
and our members continue to continually
discuss the issue um and want to make
sure that newborns are treated early and
and um this can be tracked um for their
treatment uh as appropriate but under
the current makeup of of the bill as
amended by the floor on the floor um
where where we do have some concerns
about the
Mandate thank you so exactly uh what is
the harm I guess in
requiring such a result for an infant
who does not pass the final newborn
hearing screening uh if you seems if you
take a test and you get a answer why not
I guess uh the necessity of it I mean
this bill mandates it uh mandates the
report of the result um so effectively
mandating the screening um the necessity
of of doing that for newborns um some of
the reading I've done just in you know
preparation uh demonstrates that um in
certain trials uh there were CMV screens
that did take place and um uh not all
were um flagged as positive but there
may have been more newborns uh as as
positive um you know later in their uh
early life so the effectiveness of the
test in in finding um
positive CMV but again I i' just like to
reiterate Our Testimony is that we have
concerns about the Mandate particularly
given the medical literature doesn't
support that uh um mandate after a
failed hearing
screening happy to work with anybody
though represent Leen uh thank you madam
chair and thank you very much Mr Bradley
for being here sorry that I've been so
busy and haven't followed up with you as
much as I would like um so I guess my
first question is you were talking about
the potential false negative rate of the
test um but congenital CMV can only be
cond is detected in those first 21 days
and CMV is a commonly acquired infection
through things like saliva which happen
in child care and I'm not sure if you
can send me whatever study that shows
that perhaps there's some issues with
that test you know you know I'm a data
person I'd appreciate that and um then
my other is um I'm trying to understand
the disconnect too that if this needs to
be screened within 21 days for A
congenital screening um how do we how do
we square that with the average
six-month follow-up with the audiologist
after the failed when we know that there
are treatments so a positive diagnosis
could have a change in the clinical
treatment for these children um should
they have that positive diagnosis at
Birth so just a clarifying question on
my part um you're asking about the
timeline between when a newborn is born
and the appointment with an audiologist
and how we Square the CMV
screening um within the 21 days when the
audiologist may be seen within six
months is that so I think the
audiologist would focus on the hearing
screening um the CMV test is my
understanding is not a treatment that
the audiologist would reflect on um but
I'm not a medical provider I could
certainly go back and look at that so
there may be just a there may just be a
disconnect in the treatment the the
audiologist is going to treat the
hearing whereas another provider may
help support the treatment for CMV that
okay thank you very much for that very
much appreciated the
355 yes ma'am if you could just again
state your
name and just make sure your microphone
is to the on in fact if you use the
on okay I slide right over
here good morning um Mam chairwoman and
members of the committee for the record
my name is Carolyn Drury and that's
Carolyn with YN and d y I'm from
nashwa I am a retired audiologist but
serve as the current president of the
New Hampshire Academy of
Audiology I'm here representing the
academy and in spite of all the various
iterations of this bill we are still
here standing in support of having a CMV
screening to address some of the other
issues that have been brought up um we
are disappointed that the general
education aspect of this was not
included in the floor Amendment um
because that's that's a key an excuse me
a a good piece that helps again with any
virus the more you know the mother women
of childbearing age know about the fact
that this virus virus exists and that it
they can take as with any other virus
some general Common Sense uh precautions
just to prevent them just to keep the
spread of the virus down if if they're
aware of it um as far as support both
the
American the American speech language
hearing Association and the Academy of
the American Academy of Audiology both
recommend CMV screenings
on that basis um as far as the
audiologist not being able to see the
child till 6 months later that's here in
New Hampshire um again I live in nsha a
number of people there choose to go down
to Boston Children's either in Boston or
Lexington um the baby actually can be
tested younger than that it's just a
backup um I think that unless there are
questions I think that's all I'll say
for this
time thank you very much could you uh or
do you recall if you don't have it in
front of you what in the Senate version
regarding
education you are missing from this bill
specifically you uh referred to that
general education piece what specific it
was more of an education piece whereby
um through the newborn screening task
force they would generate a brochure
that would go out to
um doctors nurs
midwives um obsti gynecologists and so
forth um possibly Public Health Centers
uh you know and just sort of start just
family practitioners just try to get the
word out that this is a a very common
virus according to CDC studies um only
one in 10 of women of childbearing age
have ever actually heard of it and if we
can increase the numbers on that we feel
would be important from a just to try to
reduce the spread of the virus as
possible as a preventative measure thank
you I've noticed you did not touch upon
the Mandate who the previous speaker uh
spoke of and perhaps you did that
intentionally just wondering if you have
an opinion on that piece um not
specifically I I don't mind have
personally having a a mandate on that
but I do recognize um that with any kind
of mandate there should be at least an
option for a parent if they so choose to
be able to wave
that okay thank you any further comments
questions represent Leon uh thank you
madam chair thank you for being here for
this um I I'm not sure if you heard the
testimony from the department but it
sounds like there already would there
would be a lot of Education that would
flow from these R making so the fact
that I accidentally left that out of my
floor AB bed hopefully isn't a problem
okay it does look like the bill has you
know naturally dramatically changed from
when it was first introduced obviously
people are working on it so uh there's
that to consider anything further thank
you very much for coming thank you for
your time and attention all right anyone
else here to comment on Senate Bill
355 yes representative walner I do have
one more question of the
thank you for coming back
up so you referred to I believe it was
hersa
you yes the newborn hearing screening
program is funded by CDC and Hera
however that funding is allocated for
other
activities not CMV screening so I would
use in future budgets a portion of that
funding so it would be that funding
would
this project this proposal could be
funded through the hersa
funding you need an additional I would
need additional funding to support the
position
so my understanding is that because uh
the CDC funds and the Hera funds are are
restricted to certain activities that if
this would be a new a new activity um to
screen for CMV and would need funding in
in however that framework worked with a
0 five or 20% of a05 to be able to
accomplish what the bill would ask the
department to do so this is not a um
function that the CDC funding or there's
a funding right now would allow you to
fund to correct correct So currently
this is not an
activity part as part of those
you okay uh for discussion purposes I
think we'll have an amendment drafted um
to include the general education piece
that was taken
out as well as the opt out
option I'm hoping there's still no
fiscal impact as a result of
that Mr Ripple is that an amendment you
could put in yes I can do that okay
we'll do
further
okay anything further from those in the
audience all right we are ready then to
Senate Bill 404 is entitled an act
relative to expanding Child Care
Professionals eligibility for the child
care scholarship program as means of
some background again with the
disclaimer that the full background can
be found on the docket at nh.gov
this bill got through the Senate Health
and Human Services committee 5 to0 it
was amended it came out of Senate
Finance 6 to0 the amendment however
passed 13 to 11 in the
Senate however in the end it came out of
the Senate on a Voice
vote it went to the house committee on
child care of which it came out 10 to
zero and then out of the Full House on a
Voice vote ought to pass with
amendment is the general background on
House Bill excuse me Senate Bill
404 let's go to the fiscal note it looks
like we do have an updated version dated
that so it came out of the Senate with
no fiscal
impact it came out of the
house I might add on the consent
calendar with a price tag of over $2
million starting in 2025 and going
through 20126 each year thereafter in
2027 any comments Mr Ripple on a fiscal
note no other than that the final Senate
version was a reporting requirement only
for HHS and they were tasked with uh
estimating the cost of the program for
future budgets whereas the version
amended by the house would establish the
okay all right anyone um here today to
404 and Sir if you could introduce
yourself naturally and make sure your
position thank you uh Brian Clark I'm
general counsel for the uh division of
economic stability part of the
Services welcome thank you so what this
bill would do is there's currently
existing Child Care Program called the
New Hampshire Child Care scholarship
program and what it does is it provides
a Child Care Subsidy uh for qualifying
low-income people who knew child care
and participate in quality qualifying
activities such as
employment and so what this bill does is
create another Child Care Program for um
child care
workers and it as a prerequisite it
would require the um child care worker
to apply for the ordinary Child Care
scholarship and we expect largely most
child care workers will be eligible for
the child care scholarship and
receive um the subsidy that way and for
um childcare workers whose incomes are
just a little too high to qualify for
the regular New Hampshire Child Care
scholarship it would provide a subsidy
them thank you you're familiar with the
Senate version I
assume uh yes I'm familiar with the um
Senate version all Senate versions do
you the one that came over to the house
that was a reporting requirement
essentially yeah it was essentially um
asking the department to take a look at
the concept um and propose it in its
next
budget is there any
similar program in other areas of law to
this so it's what it's extremely similar
to is the New Hampshire Child Care
scholarship program or are you asking
about in the way it operates and that it
provides a child a subsidy to Providers
to provide child care um the
latter what you said the specifics of
providing Child Care oh okay so the
specifics of um providing Child Care So
currently we have a child care
scholarship program and
um if a um if a parent is eligible and
they apply um at a district officer
online they can enroll their kids in
child care and then um the they um
depending on the parents income they
could be responsible for a cost
share um that they have to pay to the
provider and then the department would
pay the rest through the New Hampshire
Child Care scholarship program so this
new program would operate in a similar
way in that um the parent would be
responsible for a cost share of 7% of
their household income and then the
state would pay the provider for the
rest thank you for that any
questions representative
hold thank you madam chair um maybe I
misunderstood your question um relative
to how you asked the last question are
you asking are there any other
disciplines or departments that get a
similar credit cuz that's how I took
your question and I was going to ask
that right is this available is
something similar available to I don't
know the police firefighters teachers
any
other not to my
knowledge Pur of whole thank you um
second question is there any strong
reason why this has to be done in an
off-budget year given the almost $3
million for the first
year so um I would um it's not a
department sponsored legislation I
would um we're generally supportive of
the
concept um however we're
not I'm not really prepared to argue for
represent
priest uh thank you Madame chairman uh
sir do you have the approximate salary
range for the average child care workers
in New
Hampshire uh it was in
so it appears I don't have it on hand
but I believe it it was around1 to13 an
hour
okay so that's considerably lower than
just the
living yes that we need to live in New
Hampshire yes so um as I said there's an
existing uh New Hampshire Child Care
scholarship program and individuals with
uh household
incomes uh up to 85% of the state median
income qualify for it and can receive uh
a Child Care Subsidy that way uh this is
generally targeted at workers who uh
might have Partners or spouses who are
slightly higher income who bring them a
little over that threshold and so
there's no real incentive for the worker
to go back to work if their uh entire
wage would go to uh paying for child
care so this would cover uh the cost of
that for
them okay represent as a followup with
that and again the child care workers
salaries are considerably lower than
other public service employees like fire
and police and and Municipal wouldn't
you say without having the numbers in
front of you yeah I don't have the exact
numbers but I would I I would reckon
that's probably true thank you
representative tarki followed by
representative leyon thank you madam
chair I'm just curious if you have any
idea of um this is obviously a Workforce
kind of Bill it would have a huge impact
I believe do you have any idea of the
vacancies in Workforce for the childcare
industry or um how many spots are needed
I guess what I'm trying to get at is
this would be a potential benefit to
bring on childcare Workforce and I know
that there is a huge demand for child
care spots in the
state yeah I do not have information on
the vacancy in the classrooms uh but I
can get that for you well I guess I'm
looking vacancy in Workforce like how
many workers does the industry need okay
I as I yeah same same answer I don't
have that information from me but I can
get it for you great thank you
representative Leon uh thank you madam
chair and thank you for being here um I
do know that at least some Child Care
Centers offer free child care to
employees as a benefit of working um
what impact would this legislation in
this program have on that
practice uh so likely those child care
workers or those child care providers
would choose uh either to continue and
then ask their um workers to enroll in
this program and then the free program
would just cover the cost share the
family cost share to continue providing
that
benefit um or they would decide to
um I I can't speak to what a provider
would decide to do in that
situation thank you okay representative
hle sure um no real expertise in this
domain
um is there anything in statute that
limits or caps the current rate relative
to child care I know it's expensive I
just wasn't sure whether you're aware of
limitations on rate
setting um so there are rules Federal
rules around how we um determine what
our rates are we conduct a rate study um
and then base our the rate that the
child care scholarship pays based on
that and I can certainly provide more
detail um in a followup okay thank
you okay all set thank you very much and
I'm realizing you're the only one to
testify on this bill and you're sort of
bearing the burden of uh sponsors and
information source and everything else
so we appreciate your ability to feel
these questions and and do all that
thank you very much thank
you okay uh now I'm realizing my version
of Senate Bill 404 had all the complete
Pages included I am realizing now some
of your versions did not so I hope
everybody at this point realizes there
is a first page
and and we're all on the same page with
regards to this bill okay I didn't
realize that again because my version
was
complete okay this bill has
undergone some serious changes since its
initial
introduction um there's no one here from
the special Committee of child care come
forward
okay and do be sure to introduce
yourselves thank you very much Madam
chair um my name is Michelle Merritt I'm
the president at new Futures and with me
is my colleague hi my name is Rebecca
lovsky and I'm the child and family
policy director at new futures um new
Futures worked with a coalition of
stakeholders and child care providers um
over the last 18 months and this piece
of legislation was born from some of
those conversations there were questions
that were asked earlier um that we may
have some answers to so we thought we
would share them with you um presently
in child care in New Hampshire right now
there's a vacancy rate of about
26% um the reason why this particular
piece of legislation was put forward was
because of a um there was some
interesting work done out of Kentucky
and some other states that piloted um
addressing Child Care shortages through
Child Care scholarship for the workers
during Co the covid-19 pandemic um and
they saw with that experience a
significant difference in the retention
and their success and keeping folks in
the workplace as a result of offering
this
benefit um just for some general
awareness um the data available on Early
Childhood Workforce um in New Hampshire
specifically the largest share of
workers are between the ages of 20 to 24
if you were to look at the next age
bracket 25 to 30 you see that about half
of those workers have left the workforce
by the time they reach that particular
age bracket the anecdotal experience
that we've heard from Child Care
Providers is that a they're primarily
women um more than 95% of childcare
workers are women and the reasons why
they're leaving is because in many cases
they're having children um and they're
finding that they cannot afford the cost
of child care to remain in the workforce
so the average child care worker in New
Hampshire if they are working full-time
salaried um makes around 31 to $32,000 a
year if you have two kids though the
average cost of care is about 27 to
$28,000 um so economically for those
families the choice for the the in many
cases if it's a two- parent household
the woman to stay home uh makes more
sense than continuing to work but we
also need these folks in the workforce
because the weights for child care and
the accessibility challenges that we're
having in New Hampshire right now are
significant so that is some of the
background information on the vacancy
rate the reason why this is a targeted
piece of legislation to address a unique
problem that's specific to this
Workforce um issue and some of the
financial pieces around how much it
costs to have your kids in care and what
the average wage
is I don't know if there's anything that
you want to add um the other thing that
I'll just add is um to note that the
special committee on Child Care did add
a provision within this bill that would
require DHHS to attempt to get a waiver
to use federal funds for this program
and other states have been successful in
that as this is a practice that the
federal government through ccdf is
supportive of for all the reasons that
Michelle outlined and the importance of
Recruitment and Retention of our
childcare Workforce for our overall
health and wellness of um New
R Leon um thank you madam chair and
thank you so much for bringing this
information this this actually brings up
a question to me too it almost seems
like um if these women are leaving to
watch their two children um they if they
had an home with up to three children in
their home where it's more like a family
type uh situation which are the UN the
ones that don't require licensing she
may actually be making more by providing
care to three kids in her neighborhood
in addition to hers as opposed to
working in a child care center I don't
know if you've looked at that with the
empowerment and the impacts on the
family so I can just speak to the fact
that childcare scholarship is utilized
by center-based and atome families so
sometimes it is feasible for an
individual who lives in a single family
home to open up that home to take in
kids and we thoroughly encourage that
but sometimes that's not possible you
may have heard Bill's a session around
zoning limitations and um just the
financial inability to start their own
inhome child care we have um been
supportive of this bill because it comes
from the field from teachers from
directors from staff who wish that they
could be in the room teaching but they
simply cannot do it because they cannot
absorb the cost so again that is a
possibility and we fully support family-
based child care this child care
scholarship does but the reality is that
not every family has that opportunity
not every individual does yeah there's
not a single Silver Bullet solution to
this challenge it really is a
multi-prong multifaceted issue um so I
would encourage the committee to also
look at and support those simultaneously
moving pieces of legislation that have
care any further comments or questions
okay thank you both very much anyone
else to uh comment on Senate Bill
okay
um thoughts from the committee
my thought is Mr Ripple that we um have
an amendment
drafted uh to replace the bill with the
last Senate
version with no fiscal impact
essentially a duplicate of that um
however the the previous two
speakers You' mentioned something at the
end of your comment with regards to
something also that needed to be studied
you just um made a remark about that and
I'm wondering if perhaps that and I want
to get it specific should also be
included in the
amendment um so the last reference was
to another bill that is already moving
um related to some zoning issues that
exist um we have comment obviously and
can work with the committee around
different iterations and drafts um for
this bill to contain costs my colleague
ALS also mentioned opport unities to
pursue Federal waivers um our
organization's concern was if you went
back to the the Senate version as it
came out of Senate finance that you
would lose some critical pieces and
opportunities to move forward and seek
some of those waivers now um so we'd
urge the committee to work with the
advocacy community and others around um
potential amendments and we personally
do not support the Senate version
understood thank you okay then thank you
for the
clarification so that Amendment for
discussion purposes on Friday would be
an exact duplicate of the Senate version
nothing else to be added based on what
you said okay represent walner I am
going to um work with uh new Futures and
other organizations to come up with an
amendment that I think we could uh use
to push this bill for further um I know
because I'm on the uh Child Care special
committee we heard from a number of
providers and
um people wanting to be in the field and
also people who were providing care in
Center based or family child care
and this is a this is something they
could use as a recruitment tool and a
retention tool and this profession is
really having a hard time and because
they're having a hard time it means
other employers and other businesses in
our state are having a hard time because
they can't um attract
employees so I will bring forth an
amendment on Friday that will um look at
some of these pieces in a little bit
different
you anything further on cill
409 Senate Bill 409 is an act relative
to reimbursement for ambulance services
under the State Medicaid
plan now pause for just a moment would
anybody have any
objection if I also take up Senate Bill
455 at the same time for the purposes of
this work session which is an act
relative to Medicaid reimbursement rates
devices representative walner we have no
objection but we do the bill that we
have before us the the printed copies
also look like they are missing pages
same with the same with 417 so okay
thank you for letting me know because my
copies I got them early do not have that
issue so I appreciate that very much so
go check with ours all right that sounds
good
um at this point why don't we take a
five minute break five minutes and we'll
get the pation figured out thank
e
complete now um sorry about
that but um I I think at this point
we'll take up Senate bills
and
455 together seeing as though they
are Loosely
related so is anyone here to discuss
either Senate Bill 409 or Senate Bill
4555 and if you could come forward and
identify yourself and which of the two
or both you're here to discuss thank
you I Rob Barry general counsel of the
division of Medicaid with New Hampshire
DHHS I'm here to speak about both bills
just briefly uh we supported the policy
throughout um the the process thus far
um as far as uh sp sp 409 does not have
an appropriation attached to the bill
which we feels pretty critical for us to
be able to implement uh although we uh
support the policy we don't think we can
Implement without a uh an appropriation
and I'm happy to take any questions you
okay all right um while you're here let
me just briefly give a review of these
bills in terms of their background and
the fiscal note so Senate Bill
409 that came from Senate Health and
Human Services 5 to0 Senate Finance 7
to0 came out of the Senate on a Voice
vote came out of Health and Human
Services on the house side
18-2 and was adopted by the house on a
Voice vote on the consent calendar the
fiscal note on Senate Bill
be you have an updated version but it's
the same as the previous version okay an
uh correct okay and looks like a million
dollars of General funds and a million
of federal funds in each of the years
2027 now why is it Mr Ripple that that
does not appear on the appropriation
bills chart it doesn't contain an
appropriation it has a cost but it's not
okay any thoughts on that all right and
you are saying on 409 that this is
insufficient now that we have that
background the without an appropriation
it's insufficient as I said the policy
the department has supported uh from the
get-go and continues to support but um
we just cannot Implement without an
appropriation okay representative Leon
um thank you Mr chairman and thank you
very much for being here um it it says
that the commissioner also submit an
amendment to the State Medicaid plan I'm
just curious how long that takes and how
that impacts what the overall annual
cost of this would be so we anticipate
it take about 6 months to get a spa
State Medicaid plan uh submitted and
approved um as far as impact I I I
suppose if you go from July 1st to
January 1st then maybe you can slice
that in half for next um next fiscal
year but that's just an estimate off the
so is your
suggestion um essentially appropriation
language from Senate Bill
4555 and placing it into 409 or how do
you we do have some um appropriation
language we can offer the committee the
the 455 appropriation language um is a
bit different than than this one uh
because I think it has it's a little bit
more open-ended I think um we did put
together some appropriation language
though for SP 409 um my computer died
while I was waiting back there so I
don't have with me but I can send it to
the committee um right uh right after
I'm done here and I get some power yeah
that would be helpful okay um any
thoughts
there okay thank you very
much okay anyone else for either uh
Senate's bill Senate bills 409 or
455 all right let's move to the
that bill came out of Senate Health and
Human Services
520 Senate Finance 6 to0 through the
full Senate on a Voice vote house Health
and Human Services voted at
17-3 and then the bill ultimately passed
in the house on a Voice
vote the fiscal
note let's go to that make sure do we
have an update doesn't look like it so
the fiscal note most current is dated
March 19th that's right
okay to the tune of approximately
$620,000 per year starting in fiscal
year 25 from the general funds and
$620,000 in federal
um I wonder why
409 did not come with an
appropriation Clause how did that happen
does anyone know I don't know the
backstory to that you know um I I don't
thank you madam chair I don't know the
whole backstory on that but there
actually had been conflicting con
conditions in the drafting as it came to
health um house Health and Human
Services so I think that it was probably
representative hen
Phillips you're
recognized thank you I have some
um um background knowledge to your
question I spoke with Senator Apprentice
yesterday about this um matter in
particular and she did mention to me
that it was an error that no one caught
in the Senate process um they are aware
of it now and are hoping that that could
be addressed um and it I think it was
just a matter of the sausage being made
and somehow a piece dropped through so
thank you yes an ingredient um was not
added so um Mr Ripple why don't we if
you we could get an amendment uh on this
on 409 related to the appropriation
piece okay and that wouldn't change
anything fiscal note wise does anyone
have any questions for representative
hen
Philips okay all right I think we're
thank you very much all right and we'll
add that to the U to the discussion
agenda for Friday is the amendment doing
409 and 40 and Senate Bill
455 doesn't seem much interest in
amending that so we will take that up
for a vote on Friday anything further
Senate's bill Senate bills 409
at this point uh what do the members
think about breaking for lunch for an
hour and returning approximately 115 and
taking up Senate Bill 4 17 immediately
after lunch everyone's good all right
this division will be on break until
1:15 at that point we'll take up Senate
Bill
all
e
this is a work session of 10 bills
total for division three and five
Finance resuming from our lunch break
yet yes okay excellent so reopening work
session division three in house finance
after lunch we're going to take up
Senate Bill 417 at this point
that is an act relative to outof home
placements for
children now interestingly enough I've
located a problem on the Bill's docket
on nh.gov and I've brought it to the
Senate's attention so it's a little uh
quirky there but in review this bill
started in Senate
Judiciary with an a to pass with
Amendment recommendation 5 to0 Senate
Finance 7 to to Zer and then out of the
Senate on a Voice vote it then came to
house children and family law with an 11
to0
recommendation there was a house
Amendment proposed looks like it failed
175 to 188 there was a motion to table
that failed by four votes 180 to
184 and then the final house vote was
174 all right let's move to the fiscal
note the most recent is dated May 3rd is
that correct yes it is all right
that oh really okay so Senate Bill
4177 there's a uh miscopy situation here
does everyone else have a complete
what all right
mine I had mine with a paper
clip right there that other stack in
front no that one right there that's
yours
okay okay
great okay
um so the fiscal note reads that as for
DHHS it looks like uh 1.2 million or
thereabouts in fiscal year
2025 with a 1.7 in 2026 and a 1.8 in
2027 and then the judicial branch also
has
um costs incurred there so for
expenditures in fiscal year 2025 for
judicial branch
376,000 and that is consistent into
2027 okay any further thoughts on the
okay all right would anybody like to
begin by um remarking on this Bill yes
please step forward if you could and uh
do introduce yourself as well as make
thank you so much chairwoman Mooney and
members of the committee my name is Lisa
massio I am the associate child advocate
for the State of New Hampshire that
means I'm second in command to the child
advocate Cassandra Sanchez who can't be
with us today she's out on the road
traveling for work I'm also the attorney
for the office so I work primarily in
the legislative and policy field um I
just really want to give you all a
little bit of background I know that you
all haven't had the pleasure of sitting
through all the hearings in the Senate
and in house and children and family law
so I just wanted to just lay the
groundwork for this bill which we
drafted with Senator Whitley and a
number of sponsors as well as worked on
with the children's oversight commission
that we present to monthly so each of
the sections comes out of a different uh
situation or experience trends that we
see at our office or other issues we
work through with the oversight
commission so I'll just run through the
sections really quickly and I'm happy to
take questions as we go through um as
many of you know um from HB
1573 which we had multiple hearings and
subcommittee hearings here a month or so
ago uh our office visited bledo Youth
Academy in Gallant Texas or Tennessee
I'm sorry and found instances of
institutional child abuse so both hb1
1573 as well as this SB 43 417 some
portions are based on that
issue really having the place preference
to keep children out of residential
placement but also as close to home as
possible really reduces trauma for
children who are already traumatized
that's why they're in the system to
begin with so section one here the
presumption of imp State placement 169 C
generally is the abuse and neglect
statute so this applies to children who
are in dcyf cases this is a pre-existing
section there were just some amendments
to make it very clear that children
should be placed outside of the state
only when there's a specialized need or
program that doesn't exist within New
Hampshire and as we all know New
Hampshire is still a small state we do
have um not as many residential
placements not as much specialized
programming we're still working on
expanding our children's system of care
so this is really just building the
preference to keep the child either
within New Hampshire within New England
or in proximity to a place whether it's
a relative or kin because those people
could live outside the state and it may
make sense to have a child in a
placement near that person so and it
really does just reiterate the um
general knowledge that outof state
placements should also be limited in
time as well as require some increased
judicial oversight do you want me to
stop and take questions each section or
power through um it looks like you do
have a question now that way ask you
want to us to hold questions or ask them
as you go Section by section you prefer
it's your committee whatever you prefer
okay real good uh representative h on
that qu you know section that you just
referred to so as you go through right
you you brought up
1573 if there are overlaps
or um it conflicts with 1573 right as
you walk through each section please
note those differences for us and then
do you know why the change went from
lease restrict restrictive to less
four it could be possible that there is
a relative or fictive kin placement that
is outside the state so an instate
placement say in an Institutional
setting would be more restrictive than
say grandma in
Massachusetts so that's the difference
the level of restrictiveness starts with
keeping a child in their family home
going to a Rel ative a fictive kin
placement a foster home in their
Community foster home outside their
Community than institutional so that's
why that change in language just
acknowledges it could be that there's
someone out of state but that's still a
family like setting versus an instate
institution represent of whole thank you
for the uh as a followup there should we
try and clarify that sentence what you
just said makes perfect sense to me but
that's not the way I would read this on
its face value I think it's clarified
later in the bill when there's a very
clear
um description of from less least
restrictive to most okay um and these
bills started as completely separate
bills the overlap became when parts of
1573 got tacked onto the end of s417 in
the Senate Judiciary Committee okay so
the beginning parts are completely
distinctive okay thank you um section
two uh regarding SI siblings Uh current
language is not so clear although it is
in dcyf policy that siblings shall
remain together whenever possible it was
not clear in law this section as
currently written in law is really just
about sibling visits we have seen a
number of cases where dcyf separates
siblings sometimes out of necessity
early in a case but as they approach
permanence the policy that children
should be achieving permanence with
their siblings and unless there's an
actual danger to the siblings was not
always being followed and um there were
several cases that the office of child
advocate intervened in and felt that
this was important to clarify in law
that that sibling primary relationship
is really important and that department
shall place a child with their siblings
of course unless doing so would be a
safety concern which which does
sometimes occur and then this second
sentence does retain some of the
original language that if they're not
placed together that there needs to be
reasonable efforts that there's
visitation between the siblings so that
specific section again all of this
within 169 c um the third section here
applies to hearings for parents within a
169 C case who were not charged
originally so that would be a case where
say one parent had the children in their
care children were removed from that
parent there was Court proceedings the
state charged that parent with abuse or
neglect the court made a finding so now
the child is in fact in state custody
the other parent who was not within that
home is a non-charged parent asking for
custody often um from my experience as a
DCF and as a parent attorney often that
parent was absent so they weren't
immediately available at the beginning
of a case comes in wants placement of
their child the division does some
investigation again some of this was in
policy but there was a Supreme Court
case called Bill F that was limiting the
information that the department was
being able to gather as well as the
information available to the court now
some a lot of this language came out of
the harmony Montgomery case from the
massachusett oca's recommendations of
course we were all familiar with that
trial um I believe Mr Montgomery is
being sentenced this week so the
language really just sort of tried to
build the framework over what um would
ensure that child's safety and a parent
care who didn't hadn't been caring for
that child so and these are again
factors that the court May weigh these
are not mandatory um there's nothing
that's saying the court shall look at
every single box um some of these aren't
going to be applicable to some parents
um but it is sort of laying out all of
the different factors that may impact
that child's safety and you know Harmony
was a very public publicized case but we
see um many child deaths well in fact
our office reviews every child death but
in the last couple years there have been
a number of
high-profile um homicides of young
children by um a parent that had not
previously had them in their custody um
or another caregiver um when the state
is placing a child with anyone including
a parent they then have the liability
I'm sure you're familiar there's
lawsuits over Bon Harmony's mom is suing
the state um so this is a higher
standard where the state has the child
in their legal custody and is making a
placement that becomes State action and
state liability if they're not able to
fully investigate um the safety of the
child with that parent and this would
not apply to all cases as a dcyf
attorney I can tell you often an outside
parent would step in with you know
contact they'd say okay you look safe
the case remains open because that other
parent has ongoing abuse and neglect
case and they too have a right to have
that 12-month reunification time so very
limited circumstances under
169c um section four are two new
sections under 169
c19 19g revolves around placement
evaluations um we worked with um some of
the Specialists here in the state who
work on pediatric cases and
evaluations this just makes it clear
that the psych olical evaluation must be
supervised or conducted by a licensed
psychologist um with that specialized
training unfortunately right now some of
the assessment um evaluations are not
being done by trained psychologists they
may be being done by a social worker
maybe not even a master's level social
worker so that was a recommendation
brought To Us by um some specialized
medical providers and um to your point
uh representative hul this 169 c19 H
this is new and this lays out that
presump the um prioritization I was
talking about of what would be least
restrictive to most restrictive um the
court must first find that the child
can't remain in their home with their
biological family should that be the
case and again this is new language we
do want to presume that remaining in the
family home is in that child's best
interest only if the court has made that
finding then you would determine
the next placements you start with kin
or fictive kin um a couple of years ago
the definition of kin was expanded in
G25 to include relatives but also folks
that are not related by blood and
marriage but have a relationship with
the child or that child's family before
the placement takes place so that could
be you know someone that the child knows
their coach the teacher but especially
for young children someone you know five
and under doesn't have their own
relationships it could be Mom's college
roommate uh you know a work friend who
is involved with the family knows the
parents well you wouldn't necessarily
say a 2-year-old has a substantial
relationship but that was the language
that the this body chose to put into kin
a couple of years ago um so then
branching out from there if you don't
have any of those folks that are
appropriate or available or able you
look within the child's community of
origin you are trying to keep that child
connected with their Community with
their school with their friends with
their teachers and coaches um so that
may be with fictive kin that may be a
licensed foster home preference going to
a licensed foster home that child
already had a relationship with if they
are either a known person or had been in
care then you keep expanding to a
licensed foster home outside of that
Community particularly if you're looking
for ISO care which is a more intensive
therapeutic level of foster home un we
don't have a lot of those in the state
currently um and then there's some
language here around keeping the child
in their school of origin again those
connections for children are very
important to maintain um as they're
already in a traumatic situation having
suffered abuse or neglect being removed
from their family and then finally only
if all of those placements are exhausted
you can't find any of those or they're
not appropriate then alternative
placements may be considered and this is
where you're starting to look at what we
call institutional care which is a group
home or residential placement facility
um and then the language there around
how you're determining an appropriate
placement for a
child um section five is a Amendment RSA
169 c23 regarding returning the child at
the at the end of a a dcyf case um so
again all of that we just talked about
is under 169 C that applies only to
children that are in a dcyf abuse and
neglect
case section six oh we do have a
question oh sure sure representative Lon
and thank you madam chair and thank you
for letting me bring a question at this
section I might be called away shortly
um my first question was around the
definition of kin and then having
fictive kin show up um we don't have a
definition of fictive kin anywhere in
the statutes and it seems that the
intention is for that to be used the
same as we use the word kin um I'm
trying to understand if there's a
difference between kin and fictive kin
since fictive kin isn't defined anywhere
so that's a term of art that it's used
however it was this body that made that
decision two years ago in the 2022
session um when they expanded the
definition of kin that whatever
reasoning this body ey wasn't in this
position then chose not to change the
wording they kept it kin but expanded
that definition to include what we now
colloquially refer to as fictive kin and
that may have just had to do with some
of that had to do with the expansion of
availability for benefits to those
placements including I believe tanif so
um Senator Bradley's um s SP 498 cleaned
up some of the law with that regard and
I can't speak to what the intent was two
years ago of why that choice was made
but the current definition of kin and
170 G25
aligns with both the term kin and
fictive kin it's split out here because
a blood relative in these terms would
have preference over a fictive kin if
they both have relationships with the
child so that's why here it's kind of
split into that tier but in definition
um I I don't think we have any issue
with it remaining as this body decided
two years ago to just simply expand
definition and again it may have to do
with Medicaid billing or or just the way
benefits are given that it didn't make
sense to create two separate definitions
in that case um but here it's being used
differentially just so it's clear re
relatives blood and marital relatives
come before those fictive kin placements
as far as placement priority follow um
as a followup then it seems that we're
trying to use a narrower definition of
kin as opposed to what's in our statutes
in 17 G25 when you're talking about the
blood rated kin and then adding that
term of art that is expands upon it
would it be clearer to wherever that
there's fictive kin say kin as defined
in 170g 25 and then when you're trying
to call out the blood related kin so we
don't mess with those other benefits say
a prioritization to Kin with a blood
relationship to the child before other
kin as defined in RSA 170 dg2 I think
that would potentially be appropriate I
I think the way it is defined
currently that's why we say fictive kin
because it's still kin um but that that
could be a potential um solution if it's
concerning to you that that that term
fictive k um we would strongly encourage
though that the definition remain the
same as it is in current law I think one
of the issues that had occurred in a a
prior proposed amendment was that it
missed that group of people that had a
relationship with the family and not
necessarily the child um I saw one
version where it just said you know
relationship with a child but again you
have a kid under five they don't have
relationships really with anybody
they're too young so I would just be
careful to maintain that
that includes that full definition to
include that full breath of people that
dcyf policy and practice is currently
placing with appropriately so that's
helpful if I get one more followup
because I have to run to finance with
that followup and Then followed by
representative whole um my my concern
here is that I was already concerned
about some of the language in section
three but it seems that you said that
it's very limited circumstances I'm just
very concerned with laying this out
without having any any guard rails is
when it's used you know social proof
about me saying that JR's a great parent
is wonderful except I had a kid down the
street everybody knew that his dad was a
great parent except he was being abused
um I'm I don't know I mean to me having
that section three is very concerning if
we have a clear way to differentiate um
between how we look at one family versus
another um and I don't know if you have
a way to deal with that social proofer
if we're getting into policy but I
unfortunately need to have the shepherd
hook but I wanted to get that question
there so I don't know if you want to
follow up with me or answer this and
I'll listen to it but I have to run to
Senate Finance I I mean I can certainly
answer it because I'm sure many people
are concerned about that I mean the the
narrowness of it starts and and feel
free to call me offline if you need to
thank you um the narrowness of it starts
wherein it's it's placed in statute so
this is a very narrow circumstance where
one parent out of a biological pair of
parents has already been found to have
abused or neglected the child and the
child is in state custody so you're
talking about a situation where the
second parent wasn't involved in that at
all which that so that's that's already
a narrow circumstance that child has
been removed often and I can tell you
from my experience I spent about five
years as a parent attorney in dcyf cases
then another couple as a dcyf attorney
if there was like a divorced couple
where both parents were actively
involved usually that child would be
safety planned and that other parent who
wasn't in the household where the abuse
or neglect occurred would be the first
person that those the DCF workers are
talking to
so then this situation wouldn't come
into play you wouldn't already have had
a finding and now it's the other parent
saying hey what about me I saw this
section used when the other parent was
absent often completely out of state you
know I have parents in Arizona parents
in California so then that parent is
saying Hey I want placement of my kid
but the division doesn't know anything
about the court who needs to make this
order doesn't know anything about that
parent and the child really has no
relationship with that parent so that's
the very narrow circumstance and again
this is only when they've not been able
to work it out amongst themselves
through the normal course of a dcyf
assessment this is now a court hearing
so the judge has now been asked to
decide the parent who didn't wasn't in
the household that the abuse neglect
occurred in wants the child in their
placement still under Court oversight
because this is still an active DCF case
that parent that has finding against
some has 12 months to rectify everyone's
receiving Services everyone's still
doing monthly check-in so it's a very
narrow universe that this occurs at all
um if there are more specific questions
I can answer those but you know this is
a very very small group of people that
would ever fall into this bucket
representative hle so I'm going to come
back to section three let's jump back to
section four right um lines 20 before
and following so if I heard you
correctly regarding representative lon's
questions we could insert ahead of a on
line 26 right with a blood relative or
equivalent type thing to mean the narrow
scope of direct family members and then
start with with can or effective kin per
one 170 G25 it was that did I hear you
correctly so I to prioritize direct
family over as the first course So
currently when 7 G25 and I want to say
it's paragraph 10 but I could be
completely wrong um defines kin has to
am I right is it par it's sorry it's um
eight actually K means child or children
who for which there is a connection or
history between the child and or the
parents or another responsible adult
that's current law but I thought I heard
you say it's important to put blood
relatives ahead of that list so I was
trying to create I know but I was trying
to put that in statue so I was trying if
a is kin but kin is broadly inclus
inclusive of people that are not
biologically related do we put ahead of
a the first priority is the biological
parent or right blood relative might be
a grandparent or whatever and then it's
all the others that fall under this kin
or effective kin per 170 G25 so I would
say line 24 captures the the biological
parents all right
you're presuming that the family home so
that captures relatives I need to look
at the actual language but yeah I hear
parent right would not necessarily fall
in the family home but you could make
the argument that the grandparent or the
uncle is the preferred over the friendly
n the friend the the friend of the
family type thing and I if I heard you
correctly right we want to keep within
the family is the priority one so I
would defer to DHHS on that question
because they have policy that lays all
of that out okay we put kin and fictive
kin together to allow that breath of
because you also have uncles who aren't
blood uncles but who are closer to that
child than say a grandparent that lives
in Arizona so again the goal of this is
to respect that child's primary
relationships in community because you
want that child to feel safe and love
and secur so whoever that person is that
should be the next person beyond the
parents obviously
um I would
say you want that to be as inclusive as
possible because you could have
situations where there's blood relatives
that this kid has never met but you know
Uncle Bob lives right next door and you
know like I I would hate to narrow it so
much that you create problems for
three um I understand that you believe
this is narrow in scope and I can hear
that right because for if there's a
parent who's absent right if they were
involved that we would never have gotten
to section three per the way the process
works
um but it does kind of read a little bit
strong in terms of the person has to
prove their innocence as opposed to
presumed innocent and DCF or other DCF
in this case is the one who had who is
tasked with challenging their right so
there's no presumption of innocence in
this in the way this reads today there
is so if you look at um Roman one which
has largely not been changed this is
current law so the parent has the
opportunity to present evidence
pertaining to his her ability to care
and shall be awarded custody so that's a
shall unless the state demonstrates by a
preponderance of an Evidence so that
actually the burden of proof is entirely
on the state the parent doesn't have to
provide any evidence at all they are
presumed to be a fit parent they can of
course present whatever evidence they
want but it's a shall they shall be
awarded custody unless the state proves
by that preponderance which is the same
standard across dcyf cases that they're
unfit to perform so the presumption is
that the parent gets the kid that is
more of an affirmative defense as
opposed to in in my eyes right as
opposed to their Pres zoed fit period
strong language and they shall be
awarded in less right yes they're they
don't have to prove their innocence by
show but they still have to request the
court hearing go through the court
process as opposed to they're a presumed
fit parent to start with and that's a
very right you're still proving your
innocence by just doing the the basic
steps of going to the court and
listening to all of this you're now
proving your innocence via a process as
opposed to dcyf gets to
kick off a court request if they think
there is a reason not to presume the the
parent is innocent you see the
difference and and one actually has more
more Court effort associated with it and
that's why I'm asking so I want to be
careful about the terminology we're
using because this is not criminal so
there's no innocence or guilt so I just
want to start there the way this is
worded I I know it's worded Strangely I
didn't write this original language they
do put sort of the cart before the horse
but the way this is current worded the
parent is presumed fit the issue as I
said is that very narrow instance where
that parent wasn't immediately present
right when that other parent was found
to have abused or neglected often they
come on the scene later so that's why
there's suddenly a hearing because at
that point the state already has legal
custody of that child because the court
found that the parent who had the child
in their home had Abus are neglected so
the court ordered dcyf to have you know
legal custody of this child so that's
where it needs a hearing because the
court then needs to make a different
order presumably this child is placed
somewhere either with a relative or in
foster care the court has to then make
an
order placing the child with this other
parent who didn't have the child in
their care follow up follow up so
so is there any cases
where two parents both reside in New
Hampshire right they are not they are no
not
cohabitating
and dcyf steps in because one parent has
been charged with a crime or sorry has
been accused of of child neglect or
abuse and the other parent ends up being
tripped up by this statute that it
doesn't go it it doesn't defer to them
automatically as the next parent child
the state has has possession of the
child and or guardianship of the child
and then instead of going directly to
the parent who was never accused who is
perfectly fit who lives in the state we
get back into section three here in our
court and that just takes up additional
time and and delays how quickly we can
return the child back to his
family I cannot say personally that I
ever saw a case like this honestly in my
six and a half years of being involved
with dcyf on both sides I only ever saw
one of these
hearings so and that was not the
circumstance there um I I mean I can't
tell you has that ever happened but th
again like this section is used very
rarely but there have been some
circumstances where the section may have
been entirely bypassed or you know in
the Montgomery case it was the
Massachusetts court placing here but
this was an issue that they pointed to
specifically that a Court's placing with
a parent that neither the division nor
the court had much information about and
now a child is dead um so in my
experience the example you're giving is
not one I've seen I I couldn't tell you
if it's never happened happened one in a
million times but this due process
occurs with the presumption that that
the parent is fit with the burden on the
state and just lays out sort of the
information that the court may consider
a lot of this coming directly from cases
where children have been grievously
injured or murdered um of you know sort
of the situation that may have led to
that because really the point of 169c
and the overarching definitions you know
right at the beginning is it's focused
on the safety and Welfare of the child
because that then becomes a state
liability when children get her in
care okay go ahead and proceed thank you
very much attorney
um I think I was at section 4 169 c19 H
or no we talked about that already just
kidding I'm already at section six so as
we said so section six is Page Three
down the bottom line
27 169c only applies to children that
are involved with the dcyf system
there's also 169b which is Juvenile
Justice and 169 D which is chins or
children in need of
services so
169f applies to all three sections so we
essentially just took two pieces that
I've already discussed and put them into
F to make sure that children who are in
placement under a juvenile justice case
and a child who's taken into you know
potentially placement through court
ordered chins have those same rights to
remain in state near their family and
have the same placement preferences
because children even if they're placed
under a juvenile justice case or a
Chin's case should still have the same
right to remain with family and get
Services kin or fictive kin to be in a
foster home you know the idea shouldn't
be just be those kids immediately go
into residential placement um so that
was really just um pulling two pieces
we've talked about into 169f to to make
sure that those children also have those
same um ability and preferences um 169
F7 and 169
f8 are the exact same sections that were
on hb1
1573 but these are the um probably after
the seventh amendment in house finance
um we work very closely with DHHS as
well as the judicial system to try and
find language that sort of reduced the
workload on the workers and the courts
but while keeping sort of the primary
Protections in place so and also
representative Edwards at that time was
was wanting to sort of get the price tag
down as well so this language here was
the end product of all of those
amendments and
discussions that kind of kept the bones
of those protections of the monthly
visits and the judicial oversight but
kind of substantially reduced the
touches to reduce that price tag so for
instance in the judicial piece um
initially the bill had been written that
any child in care was having either
30-day hearings or 60-day hearings
throughout the life of the case but
under conversations with the Judiciary
that that would put a huge burden on the
courts um as well as as the workers and
would mess up the norm three-month
hearings now is just one single extra
hearing when the kid goes into
residential placement and then it just
goes back to the regular quarterly
hearings that already occur um so
similarly in the monthly visits it was
reduced a little bit to checkins the
amount of spaces they had to see was
reduced to just what that child had
access to as well as gave um the ability
to meet with the therapeutic provider
remotely because that is the one person
that's pretty busy at a facility hard to
get in touch with um but the leadership
and the um Direct Care staff are people
you'd be interacting with as you walked
around as you looked where the child
sleeps as you talked to the child um so
those were heavy collaboration between
the OCA DHHS and the Judiciary to get
the language where it is now um so the
fiscal note was substantially reduced
from the original bill as it came across
so representative H thank you so if if
all of section six is is effectively
part of the copy from
1573 is that bill still where is that
bill in the Senate so it's just the last
two parts so 169 F7 and8 are identical
to the last two sections of
1573 okay um
1573 as it left this body merely became
a statement of fact with a million
dollars with representative walner
reporting requirement it has been heard
in Senate Judiciary I believe they're
exing it
tomorrow okay thank you out of Judiciary
it has not gone to Senate Finance yet so
that one's a few Paces
behind this but these sections aren't in
so okay anything
further um we did just want to point out
the fiscal note has been substantially
reduced as well is sort of the number of
personnel we did just have a couple
concerns about sort of the number and
the types of positions um the positions
particularly the worker positions are
coming in at a level four so cpsws
typically are a a one through four Roman
one through four usually hiring is a one
or two usually someone right out of
college a four is usually a higher level
position sort of like who's then
mentoring other workers we also note
just that um the labor grade in Step
coming in at a step five is typically
not done I don't know if anyone here's
in state service um usually when you're
posting you come in a step one you can
only get up to a step four beyond that
you actually have to get dop approval
you can't hire someone at a step five
that would be a you just you just can't
so you know just a little bit of concern
about that that level um whether that
truly reflects what would actually be
hired and what impact that would have on
the fiscal note um similarly just some
concerns with the youth visit travel
costs um as we said those monthly visits
are currently happening right now that
we we have no doubt that those are all
happening many of them probably are as
thorough as as right in here
unfortunately we just encountered some
that really weren't so just you know not
sure what that extra travel is um in
that fiscal budget since they're already
doing that travel um with uh you know
whether more attorneys are needed for
one extra hearing I'm not sure that
makes sense in that you know as a dcyf
attorney if I had a case already I've
gone through the trial I'm doing the
dispo I just have one extra hearing for
a case that through the life of it would
have you know seven or eight hearings I
don't know that that adds up to two
additional attorneys again coming in at
a step five um so again we absolutely
want there to be enough workers to do
the work well um we just want to make
sure that that the fiscal note
accurately reflects what actual hiring
looks
like all right thank you representative
tersi I would just like a clarification
yep the copy I just received this
afternoon there's a fiscal note dated
April 2D however I have another copy
with a fiscal note May 3rd which is
significantly less correct we're working
off the May 3rd version that's what I
thought okay I want to make sure I'm
looking at the right numbers thanks so I
believe in the May 3rd version lines up
with the actual text of what passed the
Senate the fiscal note on the one that
passed didn't match with the actual text
so I think the update was just to match
it to the text Which is
less represent
priest thank you Madame chairman and
thank you for being here and taking my
question um if this legislative body
took into account a lower grade Staffing
rates what effect would it have on the
fiscal
note I would love to answer that but I
cannot okay but perhaps Mr Ripple could
or DHHS we just wanted to point that out
as it just didn't seem to match with our
okay I don't have an immediate answer I
would need to take a look at the exact
positions that have been requested and
the alternative positions that are being
suggested um I need to take a look at
the the salary and benefits for the the
alternative positions follow up yes
could I ask uh Mr Whipple and HHS to
work together and give us a revised
fiscal note that shows the lower rates
advocacy yep I can I can definitely give
you the difference in cost we won't
update the actual fiscal note but I can
provide the committee with that
information
yes great and I would like to we we're
not necessarily recommending we're just
asking why those and and perhaps they
have an answer of why they're coming in
at level fours step FES it just seemed
it caught our attention as something
unusual as not a typical
practice and just to clarify the reason
we wouldn't update the fiscal Noe is
because the bill itself specifies the
exact positions the department shall
hire for so the fiscal note reflects
what's in the Bill itself but I can
definitely give you the cost of the
Alternatives great thank
you so a a SE a different cost would
result in an
amendment representative whole thank you
Mr Ripple could you also note on that
fiscal note what the text would need to
change in sections 8 and section
whatever relative if we were to
implement a different different language
there what the cost reduction would be
you representative
wer I have an amendment for uh section
three that I'd like to like us to look
thank
you representative wer would you like to
speak to your Amendment yes in section
three where it says a parent who has not
been charged with abuse or neglect under
it
says shall be afforded upon request a
full Hearing in the district or Family
Court why do they need a fo full hearing
if they haven't been charged with
anything I would change that language to
say shall be deemed a fit
parent this may be challenged with a
full Hearing in the district may be
challenged but why start off with making
more work if the parent hasn't been
accused of anything thing why do they
have to start with a
hearing and the other change is at the
bottom of um all the letters on the
second page you see all the letters a
through G I would change them I would
eliminate U change a letter a and re re
uh renumber the rest of
them to a through F and then the last
thing
on that paragraph that's that's in
italics on about line 15 on page
two after um shall be weighed as a
factor in the fitness of the parent a
new sentence the fact that a parent owns
a firearm shall not make a home
unsafe like to add that because some
some people get carried away with that
stuff
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman and uh thank you chairman wer
for bringing this amendment um I have
one other remaining question in here the
on lines 24 through
25 um you kept the lines a parents
failure to cooperate with the
Department's assessment or to provide
any records necessary to such a
determination shall be weighed as a
factor in the fitness of that parent um
I'm I'm just concerned somewhat about
somebody having to prove that they're
innocent when they haven't been accused
used of anything and the idea that not
cooperating when there's not a lawful
order um it just seems to be blurring
some lines to me and that line is
concerning to me for that reason it's in
the current law and you retained it in
the
Bill Madame chairwoman may I address yes
please
um I'll start with the removal of
paragraph a the unique needs of the
child and whether or not the parent is
adequately prepared to address those
needs um that language came directly out
of the Massachusetts oca's report on
Harmony mcgomery as one of the primary
factors that led to her Murder by her
father that Harmony had some unique
needs um and that Mr Montgomery was not
able to meet those needs um which I'm
sure we've all heard the graphic
testimony of how exactly she died um
that is the only section of the proposed
bill that actually directly addresses
the child and those child specific needs
uh the rest of the language of this
section addresses the parent and the
parents um you know existing
relationship substance use issues again
a lot of that did come out of the
harmony Montgomery case but but in a
vast majority of the child deaths we see
particularly murders at the hands of
parents these are children with unique
needs they're usually very young five
and under they may be on the spectrum
they may have medical issues um you know
emotional or behavioral issues that that
are challenging to parent you know
rightfully so often they haven't been
fully um evaluated and aren't receiving
services for those issues which again as
I'm sure we all know it's it's
challenging to parent a child with those
unique needs so I would
just strongly encourage this body to
think about Harmony and that situation
and that that language is very directly
addressed at that situation um as far as
the um the the parents failure part in G
that was amended by Senator bird Cil to
to read as it reads now um that the
parents failure to coop operate or
provide records necessary to to weigh
all that stuff up above I mean that's
like a lot of stuff that only the parent
would know dcyf and the Court's not
going to know if the parent doesn't
cooperate with them and again this is
focused on the child safety and
well-being if a parent can simply say
I'm not going to tell you if I have a
substance use issue I'm not going to
tell you where I live or how I live I'm
not going to tell you if I even know
anything about that child under current
law the family court has discretion to
weigh the evidence given the the weight
that the court believes it deserves so
that sentence is really more notice to
the parent I mean if you don't want the
parent to have notice but that happens
if DCF goes in and says this parent
didn't tell us anything we we can't tell
you anything about this person or their
relationship with this child or their
ability to meet that child's needs the
judge is going to weigh that because
that's the information the court now has
is we don't know anything about this
person um
so it really already kind of works that
way the court then weighs that because
how are we supposed to make a
determination with no information so
this was
really more aimed at a parent to say
Obviously that's your choice you don't
have to cooperate if you want don't want
to but the Court's job in this instance
is to weigh the safety and well-being of
that child if the State as the guardian
of that child is it going to place that
child in that person's care so in order
to do that if you have no information to
go on that's a problem for the court
so that sentence is really meant as a
statement of this is how this process
works absolutely the state has to has
the burden of proof the person is
already um presumed fit as already in
current law but it's really hard to tell
whether a child's going to be safe with
a person whether it's a parent or
someone else if you don't know anything
so I would just put that out there as
information for you representative whole
Leon
sure um so let's go to the unique needs
of a child is there any way to better
explain that because that can be a very
broad language and unique needs could be
medical could be emotional could
be um Behavior as you said on the
Spectrum but unique needs could be very
broad as well so can the department
provide some clear Insight what they
want for Unique
needs I I would defer to the department
on that I mean I have talked to a lot of
different people and invited everyone
anyone to offer language that would
cover the situation that led to the
murder of Harmony Montgomery the murder
of Elijah Lewis the murder of buou Von
you know
what would fully capture the spectrum of
of challenging needs unique needs the
office of child advocate you know
supports this language because that is
what came directly word for word out of
the Massachusetts office of child
Advocates report on Harmony certainly if
you can find a a universe to
Encompass those unique needs that would
potentially um put that child's life in
danger if a parent was not not like
prepared to care for that I absolutely
be open to that or open to DCF coming up
with language that they thinks
encompasses that situation okay and then
to lines 12 13 14 right relative to a
parent's failure to cooperate with a
Department's assessment right that's
written as a stick just if you don't do
this we're going to hold it against you
which is as opposed to a parent's
cooperation with the Department to right
you could write it as a carrot
too um it is written currently written
as a we will we will hold this against
you you have to prove your innocence and
if you don't prove your innocence we're
going to hold it against you as opposed
to you have the opportunity to show us
why you're we you would be the right
choice and it words matter the failure
to cooperate comes across this very
strong language relative to we're going
to hold this against
you I hear what you're saying um I think
you know the first paragraph already
sets up the burden is on the state the
you know the parents already
um you could I think Senator burdell's
amendment made it such that it simply
weighed as a
factor do you know what it said before
it I do it said it will be weighed
against the fitness of that parent and
it was changed to just weit as a
factor um you could potentially I think
it may hold the the same weight if it
said a
parent's failure to provide you know the
records requested necessary to make such
a determination I I think G is trying to
encapsulate that a through f is what the
you know Department's looking for to
present to the court to may we as
factors so G is sort of a summary
so that assessment yep is then you know
used well that's what's used to present
the state's case essentially
um I I think the court being presented
with little to no evidence because the
parent chose not to provide it yes there
probably is a nicer way to say that than
failure to cooperate but the essence of
it is if everybody shows up in court and
the department says we can't really tell
you anything judge because this parent
didn't answer any of our questions let
us into the house provide any
information do what you will with it
Court that's sort of that paragraph is
going
I sorry I think this goes to the heart
of the amendment that um represent
chairman Wier provided to us right which
is we're still back to the parent
needing to do enormous amount of effort
to prove their
innocence relative to
being considered a potential place or
place a potential place to place the
child and it's this type of verbiage
here here that kind of is this huge arm
twisting by government to mandate
someone's innocence and I'm trying to
get away from that I'm trying to get to
a paradigm where the parent or the
effective kin is Presumed Innocent in L
type this only applies to the biological
parent okay not kid this is purely when
a biological parent who was not you
typically normally on the table at the
beginning of a case is now coming in
saying
M I know my child's been removed from
that other parent here I am um paragraph
one in the in the bill not in the
amendment is how the law stands now I I
agree that the wording is a little
clunky the presumption is there though
that that parent is fit the burden is
entirely on the state to prove they're
unable to care for the child but again I
I would shy away from the word innocent
because this isn't a criminal case but
in 169
the court is tasked with protecting the
not just the court DCF right the whole
reason they exist is to protect the the
safety and well-being of children
they're not just running around taking
children away from parents like this is
already a situation where they've
investigated they found that the the
current caregiver of the child has
abused or neglected that child something
has happened to that child child is now
court ordered into State care this is is
the situation we're in so now it's up to
the court in dcyf to make sure that
child remains
safe so it does presume the parent is
fit but that piece of the welfare of
that child being the primary factor now
when the court determines where I'm
going to court order that child to live
these factors weigh in so I I do hear
where you're coming from of how that
feels
but I just want to be careful about this
does still presume Fitness and there's
not guilt or innocence this is not a
criminal proceeding it's merely to
protect
children representative Leon um thank
you madam chairman and thank you um I I
I still come back to this unique needs
of the child we need to Define that
better because if a child is a drummer
and the other parent lives in an
apartment where it's going to be a
problem for them that would be a unique
need where they might not place them
with it with that parent I know that
seems kind of out there but we need to
be careful with what our language says
and legislating um out of emotion from
something even as tragic as what what
was experienced we just need to make
sure we're more precise in the language
so I really would encourage better
language I am not a social worker even
though I play one on TV occasionally I
am an attorney I would you know I think
that's a great question to ask dcyf
maybe an actual field worker or an
assessment worker you you know the folks
that are doing the work in the field
that would be reading this or or any
definition of how they would interpret
that honestly from my background in this
field I would never think to interpret
that to mean a kid wants to play the
drums loud you know when when I see
unique needs of a child I do think about
those
challenging medical behavioral you know
emotional disregulation so you know I
would in you to ask social workers
especially like DCF field assessment
workers You Know Field administrators I
I think Marie's still here Marie Nan
who's the director of DCF um how they
would interpret that because again there
are terms of art that are used in social
work in this field that
I I wouldn't begin to say but I would
never have occurred to me that reading
this that's what someone would interpret
it to say you can't parent your kid
because you live in an apartment like
that there's a number of reasons why
that would not be the case um but I I
think that's a great question for them
if they have some other idea how to
capture those situations and use a more
definitive terminology
absolutely okay thank you attorney masso
that's that's quite a lot but you
presented very well and very clearly and
we appreciate that and I'm happy to work
with anyone if you have Amendment
language or you know we we're here to
collaborate and uh keep the world safe
for kids thank you at this point uh if I
could have maybe uh Miss Morris um Miss
Nan come
forward uh there are a few broad topics
here that were touched upon in the last
hour that perhaps you could give
clarifying thoughts on I can list them
to sort of narrow
this definition of
kin Warehouse Bill 1573 relates to
417 I know there is an audit process
going on currently where we are with
that and where these bills fit into that
and then just most recently unique
needs so if we could um begin with that
and then whatever additional comments
you want to those four that would be
helpful representative wer could I get
the
names sure uh my name is Christa Morris
I'm the director of intergovernmental
Affairs first name again Christa k r i
s Morris
Morris hi good afternoon Marie Nunan n o
DCF thank you representative walner were
you going to suggest that as well I was
I was just going to add to the list that
they go over the um fiscal
note so five broad topics there um to be
discuss thank
you sure so we can start with the
fictive kin piece um this was language
brought forward by the OCA and so we
haven't really had much input regarding
fictive kin um I believe that we
supported the the concept of of adding a
definition but we
also were not opposed to not adding a
definition because we already use
fictive kin in our in our policy and
procedure um and I'll leave do you want
to expand on
that no
okay um so then regarding 417 SB 417
versus hb1
1573 um as you may remember this
committee decided to um create a $1
million appropriation to the department
in hb1 1573
that would include um or with
that we have to basically use that
million dollars on items pertaining to
the residential treatment of Youth the
residential placement of Youth
and it was to look at our internal
policies procedures see what needs to
happen what can we do with that million
dollars to better our program and then
come back to you later on in a reporting
requirement uh brought forward uh on the
floor to then just say what what changes
should be made what do we need to do and
then how do we come back to you later on
to ask for those changes if if they need
to be be statutory and to provide you an
update that is currently with Senate
Finance or Senate Judiciary I believe um
Lisa stated that and that is due to be
exec out
tomorrow um I've heard Rumblings of an
amendment but I'm not sure I haven't
seen one so I don't really know um where
that is but currently I would say there
is no policy overlap between the two
that kind of changed within this
committee before it went to the
floor representative walner sort of
jumping ahead here but is there any
fiscal overlap so the million dollars
that was in
1573 as it left here with no real
definition as to how it was going to be
spent Could That Could those funds be
used for any part of the fiscal needs of
this
bill in theory yes um the the million
dollars was to take uh we did provide
actually a um an outline so to speak to
Senator Carson she did request that you
know what would we look to do with that
million dollars so I did provide that to
her over at Senate Judiciary uh that
includes we are currently looking at a
system of care uh looking at policies
and procedures internally as well as
statutes to see what could be changed
and what needs to be changed looking at
the uh Behavioral Health uh database
that we would like to set up to be able
to streamline more of the certification
process things of that nature that we
would like to look at as for overlap
with Senate Bill
417 I mean there could be overlap there
it could be but it wouldn't necessarily
MH is that it okay so then we have the
LBA audit that a close
quickly so in
April the legislative performance audit
and oversight committee did discuss
looking at
um an LBA audit as to the interplay of
the division of dcyf and our Bureau of
children's Behavioral Health targeted
specifically at this topic um let me
read this out loud there's an interest
in the interplay between DCF and bcbh
which often worked with the same
children and how the outof state
placements happened so that is also
going to probably come to fruition we
anticipate that we will have to engage
in that audit and and provide the LBA
with our current policies and procedures
and how that is um being handled at the
time at this specific time right now
passing the children's uh Bureau of
Health and so we do anticipate that
audit will look at things that may be
changing due to
legislation um and and so it may re make
re it may end up making recommendations
to to current statute that is outdated
and that's something um that is just
something we kind of have been thinking
about this past week as as that audit
has come to light um and then we have
the unique needs of the child I will let
Marie expand more on this however ever
the department already looks at the
unique needs of the child when it comes
to the mental physical emotional health
of the child so as for a definition we
could include some of that language but
really um it's something that is already
done within the department so to provide
a
definition I I don't really know but if
Marie could go ahead and expand on that
sure when we're looking at the best
place uh safest place for any child we
certainly do take into account their
unique needs and and if I were to think
about defining those they would include
things like um the unique safety needs
of that child um emotional mental health
educational needs developmental needs
and medical needs um so that was the
list that I um came up with as we sat um
advocate representative Leon um thank
you madam chairman and thank you for
that um bringing up the educational
needs um could you let me know how
that's prioritized is homeschooling
looked at differently as than public
school than private school than Charter
or are they viewed on an equal playing
field those would be viewed on an equal
playing field it would be uh when I
mentioned education it would be is the
child experiencing an IEP um is the
parent able to meet whatever needs might
come up through that certainly that's a
School driven process but is the parent
able to um follow through with any
requests of the school and and whatever
is unique about the child's needs not
necessarily the location of the of the
school
placement okay anything further
for um yes go ahead uh yep and then
there was the fiscal note request right
so the fiscal
note I know there are questions about
the level of Staffing uh we did have a
recent reclassification go through at
the state and so we that that does play
into this include to include those
higher level staff but also uh the the
reason for the higher level staff the
higher level CPS WS is partially because
these cases are much more detailed
they're much more intense and so you
want those those staff who are at a
higher classification level we are able
to hire at a higher um
at rating it's just we may not be able
to but we are able we're able to it
doesn't mean we'll have the applications
for it I guess is the way to word that
um so really it boils down to we are
able to and again these are higher level
cases these are much more intensive so
you want those people with more
experience who are going to be able to
cases representative
priest thank you madam chairman for for
taking my question and thank you for
being here back to your audit it sounds
very much what you're doing now for your
audit for this problem that what we are
what you are being requested by HB
1573 I mean the
similarities
are are are they similar and if so is
this is HB
1573 a duplication of what is being done
in the audit right now the audit I think
would be supplemental to 1573 like I
said 1573 would allow us to put some
money towards uh creating a new database
if if that's what our findings come to
um that came out to I think
$250,000 to be able to create the the
certification database so that we can
allow the OCA viewing access to view
those files rather than us having to
bring a thumb drive over to them it
would also allow us to start possibly
the implementation and working with uh
any findings within an audit internal or
external from the LBA it would allow us
to start working on making those changes
trying out new programs trying out new
policies and procedures to make sure
they work and are are effective for for
to meet the needs of
Youth followup and as a followup again
on the unique needs again is that is
that explained or defined in a place
access I'm not certain if it's in our
DCF policy I can look at that and get
back to the back to you in the in the
committee
um the considerations that we take into
place in in having that less restrictive
or least restricted placement is
certainly outlined in our policy I don't
know whether unique I doubt is is
defined explicitly but the ways in which
that we assess for meeting a child's
needs would be in our dcyf policy follow
up as a followup you know I can see the
unique needs because of the background
that I have come from um having a
brother who has unique needs but you
know there is some
others out there that may conru it
totally different so I think that would
welcome okay anything further for Miss
Morris or Miss
Nan okay are others here wanting to
speak on Senate Bill 417 sure come
forward and just be sure to introduce
yourself naturally and make sure your
on you've been waiting very patiently so
thank you thank you very much I'll try
and be very brief um I'm Heather Raymond
I'm the representative for NASA
Hillsboro District 5 um I'm on the child
and family law committee um and just a
little bit of background um before I
moved to New Hampshire I was a forensic
interviewer in New York state um I work
for child protective there um and also
with our local law enforcement
interviewing child victims of sexual and
physical abuse um and then I worked at
DCF until 2014 um and then I worked for
Casa for a year as a program manager um
and then I got a brain tumor and then I
got better and now I'm here um so I know
quite a bit but my day-to-day experience
in the field is about 10 years old um I
just wanted to mention um a couple of of
things on the bill and and the amendment
um we talk a lot about unique needs of
the child and I know that that people
are are struggling with that definition
just want to remind us all that in these
circumstances these are children who
have been already found to be abused and
neglected and they're being potentially
placed with a parent who does not have a
relationship with them so typically this
is a parent a child for example Harmony
mon gony we know who lived in
Massachusetts who had some developmental
delays and she's being placed with a
parent that no one has ever met with no
questions asked and fre quently this is
what happens when you have a parent who
hasn't been involved we have to make
sure that the parent who is now going to
assume custody of a child who has
experienced a traumatic event is
prepared for the level of stress that
will come with that type of parenting
and that they are prepared to meet the
child's individual needs so we have to
look at whether or not the parent is is
um has the capacity to do it and if they
don't dcyf needs and the court system
needs a way of um providing services for
that parent where they're not just
dropping them off and wiping their hands
of it so for example um you wouldn't
take a child who is deaf and doesn't
have a relationship with one of their
parents who doesn't speak sign language
and just drop them off and walk away
without making sure that that parent can
a communicate with the child and B
access services for the deaf this is a
real issue here in New Hampshire where
there is only one place where a child
can receive those Educational Services
and that is in nsha so it this is
something that a judge really should be
thinking about so that they can help the
parent to get there um the office of the
child advocate mentioned several child
deaths that we've had over the last
several years and in almost every one of
those cases there was a child with a
developmental delay a child who was
non-verbal or a child with other medical
or development Al needs that was placed
with a parent who didn't know anything
about the child's developmental needs
and wasn't given any assistance on how
to meet them and so if we take away the
language that allows the court to
consider those needs then we're staying
in the same position where we're taking
kids literally out of the frying pan and
potentially putting them into the fire
so just I want to be really clear about
how dangerous and not Child Focus this
is so we want kids to have relationship
ship with their parents but we want
those relationships to be successful and
healthy especially when the state is
going to be on the hook for liability
for placing a child with a parent who
then murders them because you better
believe that that first parent is going
to sue the state so um so that's on that
section um regarding kin I just wanted
to bring to the committee's attention um
some of the testimony that we had
received in our committee um about a
family where they was um Mom and Mom's
long-term boyfriend who'd been involved
with the children since they were like
babies um biological dad is no longer
around um when those children needed
placement they went to boyfriend's
grandparents because they had known
those grandparents since babyhood and
they were the closest relative but there
was no DNA shared there so we want to be
careful that we're not going to ship
kids like that off to you know
or Minnesota or someplace because they
have an aunt there when there are
fictive grandparents who live next door
um and then the other thing I would like
to say is just on um the fiscal note um
417 asks for eight child protective
workers two jpos and two attorneys um in
testimony in our committee um we learned
that there are less than 10 children
placed out of New England it's actually
I think gone down since then so I don't
know why we need eight additional
workers to visit 10 children um and I
would hate to see a bill that does a lot
of good get tanked because of um an
overinflated cost so those are my three
points and I know we've talk this bill
to death today thank you representative
representative Lyon um thank you madam
chair and thank you representative for
being here and providing this
information um you're on child and
family law and I believe the committee
Amendment came out with support of the
full early to pass his Amendment came
out with full support that's not true
the committee Amendment did not pass
with full support the committee
amendment was split sorry but you voted
on not to pass as amended so I voted
against it as did um representative Greg
okay thank you I thought it had come out
with a unanimous from the committee so I
thought that's what the record said it
did not and we corrected that for the
record um we both Greg uh representative
Greg and I um had significant concerns
about unique need of the child um and so
we voted against it on the day of the um
Committee hearing okay thank you because
the record says the vote was 11 Zer um
so that's where the confusion comes if
you have other language for The Unique
needs it seems that there is are those
specific points I mean I think that
personally I think that it could be you
could you could stretch it out instead
of unique needs you could talk about the
individual educational emotional
developmental you know Etc needs my
concern with really listing them all is
what if we miss one
right I go back to um how we started
over an hour ago with the uh the docket
online for this bill is not accurate and
correct I've brought this to the
attention first of all the first line is
not accurate it's a duplicate of like
eight lines down and now uh you're
saying that there was not a unanimous
vote I'm sorry let me let me back up a
bit we voted against the amendment I
think at the end of the day at the end
of committee um uh representative Greg
and I voted to advance the bill even
though we felt that the amendment made
it flawed and then during house session
you'll notice that as we talked to the
office of child advocate and other reps
that is how the amendment failed during
house session so I apologize I misspoke
earlier okay thank you anyone else for
representative
Raymond okay thank you very much very
okay anyone further on Senate Bill 417
yes please come forward and of course
microphone good afternoon Aaron krian
General Council for the judicial branch
um because the judicial branch does not
take policy positions the very important
questions that you have been weighing
are not questions that I can help you
with but I certainly can uh raise just a
couple technical issues for judicial
implementation of your policy Vision uh
one of them is relatively small I think
it was in the um amendment that was
rejected for other reasons but in a
couple of places section four section
six there's a reference to presuming
that remaining in the family home is in
the best interest of the child under
federal law and state law it has to be
contrary to the welfare of the child
before they're removed from that family
home so it is actually a stronger
presumption of remaining in the family
home uh and so that's one of the things
that a judge would might read it and
think that you might be trying to adjust
that standard and I don't understand
that to be your
intention representative hle thank you
madam chair can you get for us that
reference at the federal level that
would be great thank
you and a a second one which is
something that is a little more
open-ended and I know this has been a
little bit of a challenge to resolve but
there are about three places in the bill
where it refers to the fact that uh the
court needs to determine whether the
needs of the child cannot be met by kin
fictive kin uh or in a foster family
home and only if they cannot be met can
they be put in residential placement um
this leaves a little bit of a gap for a
judge in terms of when those things are
possible for the child but they're not
available we don't have a a kin fictive
kin or F or Foster Family Home available
this this does unfortunately happen from
time to time um what you think should
happen in that scenario I'm not trying
to tell you uh but the bill is silent as
to it and what I wouldn't want is for
judges to do something other than what
you want to have happen in that
situation um whether you want there to
be some sort of temporary placement
whether you want there to be placement
residential gos that is all that is
available uh you others may have policy
opinions but I don't want judges doing
different things because they don't know
what the legislator's intention in that
scenario
is uh and then the very last thing
extremely small but in section two
there's a reference to district and
family court which is in the existing
statute uh whenever we can we generally
try to fix that to Circuit Court those
courts were Consolidated into the
2011 thank you any questions for the
judicial
branch okay thank you very much all
right representative hle I do have one
other question for Miss Nunan if she's
so I'm struggling with right this
presumption of innocence of the parent
and I'm trying to better understand
let's say there is no parent available
for some unfortunate circumstance right
there is a parent mom or dad and there
is no other direct parent at this point
available to place the kid with and for
what whatever reason the the relatives
are not optioned so we're now looking at
foster care we're looking at some other
ideally right placement what is the
Department's policy how do they then vet
the next
option so if there if there is no parent
and then there is no relative that's
where we expand to the kin meaning just
other people that have a relationship
and are known to the
child so walk me through that process
because we have outlined here a very a
very detailed process relative to the
fitness of the parent in section three
but I'm trying to understand that
process versus the same process that
would be used for some
other some other Guardian sure in any
case we do have to take into account the
child's needs and the prospective
caregiver's ability to meet that child's
needs so the same set of circumstances
that I outlined in terms of any medical
needs any developmental needs so that
sort of going through that um array of
impacts that there may be on a child we
need to make sure that the person that
were're the prospective caregiver is
able to meet that child's unique needs
and so we would start by meeting with
them we would um conduct safety checks
um to include criminal record checks we
would um assess we would um ask them to
sign a release for our own central
registry to see if they've been founded
of abuse neglect um we do that with um
adult and El elderly as well so we'd go
through some of those safety checks and
then we'd be conducting a home study
where we'd meet with them we'd meet with
all household members and just be
walking through with them what's their
relationship what and and and again what
is their ability to meet the child's
needs okay we'd also think about if I
could add some things around permanency
so what's the final outcome for the
child um initially it's always
reunification so their willingness and
ability to work with the birth family um
so there's there's an aray of things
that we look at to make sure that that
the F prospective family would be able
to meet the child's needs thank
you okay thank you very much thank you
okay anyone else on Senate Bill 417 sure
miss
Morris hi um so this is regarding the
fiscal note I know there was a question
about the number of cases and I just
want to clarify this was not 10
positions or 10 cpsws and then two
attorney
uh for 10 cases our residential
treatment in state and out of state and
out of region totals for DCF alone 250
cases Juvenile Justice is 97 and that's
totaling
347 cases so I just want to let you know
that we it is for a larger number um and
then if you want to I'm
and then Juvenile Justice JJ that's 97
youth now if you're also looking at
those in the community foster care with
Ken um that's another total of
cases representative H do you have the
current Staffing level numbers to manage
that set of almost 1300 kids the current
do I have the number or do we are we the
number of how many people we have in
Juvenile Justice how many attorneys we
have if I recall there was 33 attorneys
currently within the department managing
right yeah I can get those numbers for
you representative walner I just
wondered if the department has what is
your case like running at this point
approximately uh 13 cases per case
worker and that is about 27
children
and what would you anticipate it would
drop to with the new positions this is
to maintain
that okay yes just to maintain um
because of the extra work that would be
required of the staff it would drop a
little bit but because it would it would
maintain sorry the workload not the case
load necessarily uh because of the
expanded visits and things of that
you okay thank you uh sort of to recap
we do have an amendment from
representative Wier it's numbered
1768 H and I have as a result of this
discussion about three follow-up items
from various people who have testified
in front of us that would be helpful for
more information to the
committee um I could go over those but
I'm sure uh individuals have their
marching orders essentially for what's
needed to have more information come to
US Representative hle I have a question
for um representative
wer it is my understanding that the
current schedule has us meeting either
Monday or Tuesday for a full Finance
exact right if if we have stuff to exact
yes okay this committee meets again
Friday and they may have some results
that is correct and I was going to go to
specifically this bill for Friday I have
a high interest in this bill
unfortunately I am out of state for a
college graduation Friday morning um is
there a possibility that we ceue up
ahead of time the division 3 meeting
prior to whatever our next exec is I
guess I'm asking this is either for our
chair for division 3 or you that we
somehow allow for this to be done some
other day than Friday no because of
other people that had things mornings
and T on morning on Monday and Tuesday
1:00 Monday afternoon two 1:00 Tuesday
afternoon we don't have anything the
mornings does that help that would be
great you'll be able to get here Monday
afternoon if there's no objections from
my colleagues on the right the rest of
division three to do something on Monday
that would be great thank
you so you're asking for a another
division three meeting on this bill for
Monday afternoon is that your re no no
more of the exact for division three on
this bill on this bill instead of on
okay all right why don't we um when is
the calendar notice due Mr
Ripple I'm not sure how far ahead it has
to be noticed it's also possible that on
Friday uh the chair if you're chairing
or representative Edwards is chairing
the chair could um recess until recess
this bill until
Monday I would prefer
that okay thank you representative
priest as a clarification we're going
to make recommendations on the bills
today that we're working on except for
this one and then we're going to adjourn
and come back on Monday at 1:00 so
representative ho can be here to make a
recommendation
and then we'll have the full finance
committee on Tuesday is that correct
well I plan for execs both Monday and
Tuesday at one oh for for both days okay
that's what I'd like to clarify so when
are we actually going to as division
take up this bill Friday Friday okay got
it
okay and I was asking that if it
couldn't be taken up Friday could we
take it up
Monday
Y what I would suggest to sort of um
organize this is that we put this bill
on the calendar for Friday along with
everything else we've done today so all
10 of these bills are going to appear
again publicly noticed for
Friday at that point representative
Edwards will be chairing this meeting on
Friday I'll make it known to him uh the
fact that you're absent I know you've
made it known to him
already and if it's within his purview
to recess on Friday and then discuss
with all of us our availability on
Monday um we'll try to make that work so
in other words the Monday availability
will be a discussion point for
Friday is that
fair okay thank you so that's where we
are on this
um if anyone else has any further uh
thoughts or ideas for amendments they'd
like to bring up now obviously this is a
lot to digest and we have some
additional information coming forward to
us which will be an additional digestion
on this um any thoughts or discussions
at this point representative Hall I
would like to start on an amendment that
touches on some of what was in section
three in representative wier's Amendment
1768 but also address um and clarify the
unique need of the
child um in section three I guess it's
sorry section two and then reference the
RSA 170 G25 I have a bunch of notes here
and then let's look at the labor
positions my only concern is this bill
may not make it given the cost this year
so we we might want to look back to the
number of positions did you say RSA
17325 170
G25 okay
that would be page two line 26 okay
we'll expect to see that then when you
have it early I think it would be best
to circulate it early considering our
time frame and also we're reminded uh to
remind all of you that all of these are
due out by May 16th they have to be out
by the house finance committee May 16th
so our time is tight uh but uh the
sooner you get us that and thank you for
the overview the better anything further
all right lots to discuss lots more to
come on that I'm sure let's close it
then then on Senate Bill
417 would anybody object to a
five-minute break at this
point good uh we're going to take a five
minute break and then when we return
next up Senate Bill
minutes
e
okay we're going to resume after a 5
minute break here on on division three
house
finance next up is Senate Bill
456 and that's an act relative to the
state loan repayment program for
qualified nursing professionals and
therefore so by means of some background
this bill started in Senate Health and
Human Services 5 to zero then Senate
Finance 6:1
it got out of the Senate on a Voice vote
went to house Health and Human Services
came out with a vote of 11
to9 and
then came out of the house on a Division
vote
177 and again the full docket is on
nh.gov
anyone here to discuss or remark on
Senate Bill 456 yes please come forward
and if you could state your
name though our clerk has not resumed
quite
yet hello um my name is Whitney Hammond
I'm the bureau chief for the Bureau of
prevention and wellness in the division
of Public Health Services which is where
our rural health and Primary Care office
is located which is the office that
oversees the state loan repayment
program okay um so I'm here to just give
um a little bit of additional detail
about what this bill proposes and how
that fits with our current um slurp
program which is what we call it um so
the slurp program is um primarily
focused on loan repayment for providers
a range of different provider types are
now included in the loan repayment
including nurses which is what this bill
is specifically allocating funding for
um we also do loan repayment for
Physicians dentists behavioral health
professionals um the focus is in
recruitment of those provider types into
medically underserved areas in the state
so we specifically um support providers
who are working in what are called our
health professional shortage areas which
is a federal
designation um the other Focus for the
program is in getting providers in
Primary Care settings as opposed to
inpatient settings this bill would
appropriate an additional
$300,000 to the student loan repayment
program for state yet fisal year
25 um just for context we have $720,000
in state general funds for um State
fiscal year 25 that is already allocated
and contracted out with provider types
so all of our funding is currently in
contract this would be additional to
that um what else is important uh the
the $300,000 amount for nurses would
cover an additional potentially six
aprns or up to 10
RNs um the the way our program is
structured we can um do loan repayment
for part-time RNs as well as full-time
RNs and just by provider type the
reimbursement amount differs
so between six to 10 provider providers
would get a additional loan repayment
with this 300,000
appropriation and I'm happy to answer
any
questions thank you uh for your
testimony and thank you for the review
of the fiscal note we're all looking at
fiscal note dated April 9th 2024 as the
most recent and current fiscal note like
you say with an appropriation of
$300,000 for both fiscals years 2024
any comments on that representative Wier
followed by representative walner
followed by representative
tersi I missed what you were the bureau
chief of it's a new Bureau called
prevention and wellness prevention and
wellness
and also the people that are getting the
720,000 are they also in this same
program or in a different program
they're in the same program thank you
very much and I did you just reminded me
there was one other point I wanted to
make which is that this bill would also
ask that the department establish a new
loan repayment program to fund repayment
for nurses that don't qualify for State
loan repayment and that would be nurses
that are practicing and not medically
underserved areas as well as in
inpatient settings and outside of
Primary
Care thank you representative
walner thank you do you um president we
have nurses who are waiting for or I
mean I assume you must have some sort of
a wait list for the next people who will
be eligible for this yeah I can't give
specifics I could look I could get them
from the program staff um but it is a
program that's done on a rolling basis
so first come first serve so it there is
potential that there are RNs aprns and
other provider types that just aren't
able to get loan repair because we've
already contracted out the full amount
okay thank you
sure representative
priest thank you Madame chairman and
thank you for being here and the service
that you provide um is there any
stipulations that the individuals that
are receiving the state loan repayment
program if they have to stay in the
state in these rural areas for a period
of time
afterwards thank you sure they so there
is a requirement that they sign a
contract with their employer that they
commit to working for either two years
areas representative leyon um thank you
madam chair um if they do not uphold
that contract does the contract say that
the money is then repaid yes yes they
would default thank
you so the state loan repayment program
includes what
else do you mean what else in terms of
Provider types yes um so I let me see if
I can do this from memory um I know so
provider types Physicians um Physicians
assistants as I said aprns RN psych
psych
RNs uh Behavioral Health like Masters
and so Social Work
providers um marriage and family
therapists I
believe um dentists and then dental
hygienists as well those were the most
newly added provider types where can
that list be found on our website on the
website okay and what is that do you
have that address by chance oh gosh um
if I believe if you Google yeah um New
Hampshire DHHS
slrp student loan repayment program it
will come up okay and I'm happy to
provide a
link okay representative
tersi did have a question after all um
when you said that the $300,000 in this
bill would cover 10 RNs it doesn't
specifically require that it's divided
that way are you just saying in general
it would okay so some of these portions
of can be given out in different amounts
or I don't know I'm I'm wondering it
yeah it is it's a little bit complicated
on our website we give the detail of the
the different reimbursement amounts so
it sort of there are two factors one is
if you're full-time or part-time so that
would impact how much and how long your
contract you know requirement is so
that's the difference between two and
three years and then your provider type
and it tends to be structured where your
loan repayment amount is higher based on
if the degree type that you have is is
likely to be more costly so an MD or a
dentist gets a higher reimbursement
amount than a um masters in social
work I have one other clarifying
question please follow up so this isn't
necessarily a
full rep repayment it's just a partial
that can go towards correct okay thanks
yep so essentially this would add
nursing professionals to the group is
that fair to it is summarize so nurses
are currently eligible for State loan
repayment so what this would do is to
set aside the
$300,000 to specifically allocate to the
repayment of nurse
loans
okay anything further yes representative
Leon um thank you madam chair um looking
at this um the decision to only cover
nurses and not um Obstetricians or
anybody else that's another area that um
we need more providers in was it just
because it was the nursing community
that came forward with this request I
believe it yeah it has to do with the
how the bill originated there was an
interest in supporting nurses more
broadly in the state so the original
Bill did not focus in on medically
underserved or Primary Care settings
you okay anything further uh yes
representative priest thank you madam
chairman
um to your knowledge or do you have any
statistics that how many nurses are in
need in these rural or disadvantage
areas that this bill could pertain
to how many nurses are in need in those
areas how many yeah nurses are in need
uh in these areas
payment um I don't have statistics we do
have we so we fund Workforce recruitment
efforts through the primary care
Association in the state and they're
always actively trying to help with
recruitment of providers for rural areas
the the student loan repayment program
the real intent behind it is to actually
enable the organizations in these rural
areas to to recruit people right so it's
I see it more as the the there is a need
from these provider um organizations to
get nurses into positions and there's
just frankly always a need and this can
be a a reason that a nurse might choose
to work in a rural area or an
underserved
area follow up uh but you don't have any
numbers as to what the need is in these
areas I I could probably get a vacancy
number for you guys from a recruitment
center thank you representative Wier
thank you is there a maximum Grant
person there is and I don't know it off
the top of my head but I want to say
75,000 that looks right I found your
website and I think that's right uh
prepared to commit via State contract to
$75,000 representative hle thank you um
are the two and threee limits in statute
or is that policy oh good
policy okay anything
further thank you very much for the
information thank
you anything further Senate Bill 456
from those in the
audience
okay um I would encourage the members to
go to the website it was just as um our
last witness stated very easy to find
and take a look at that the state loan
slrp uh for further information
there okay anything further on Senate
Bill
456 all right we'll take that up on
463 Ana expanding access to courta
appointed councel for children
independency
proceedings so by means of some
background this bill came out of Senate
Judiciary 5 to0 Senate Finance 7 to zero
came out of the Senate on a Voice
vote it then went to Children and Family
Law and was endorsed there 11 to Z came
out of the house on a Voice vote as for
the fiscal note it looks like the most
2024 approximately 1.5 million of
General funds in fiscal year 20 26 as an
expenditure and .5 million in federal
funds and then the same for f fiscal
year
2027 coming from General funds Mr Ripple
do you want to add anything to the
fiscal
note the only thing I would point out is
that the bill contains an appropriation
in fiscal year 25 however you can see
that the effective date of the entire
Bill including the appropriation is July
1st 2025 which is the first start of the
the first day of the next fiscal year so
the department wouldn't actually be able
to access the appropriation contained in
the bill as it's written
now okay all right welcome Mr Williams
and welcome Miss new in once again I
take it you're here to talk about Senate
Bill
463 um John Williams director of
legislative affairs and with me Marie
Nunan interim director for DCF welcome
and we're we're here to essentially take
questions from the committee uh the uh
Bill does not have a fiscal impact as it
relates to the current state fiscal b or
the current bium and any impact would be
incurred as Mr Ripple had pointed out uh
beginning in state fiscal years 26 and
27 uh we certainly um are here to answer
any questions that the committee might
have or division three might
have so I guess one big one to start out
is uh naturally asking in one ask for
five new attorneys and 14 Child
Protective Services
workers uh seems like a lot and if
that's a really an accurate
staff request for something of this size
as I understand 124 children would be
affected yes and and to begin with with
the five staff attorneys we have to keep
in mind what the purpose of this
legislation and is to expand the scope
of access for children in dependency
proceedings to having a right to request
um um legal counsel to represent them
and in that uh capacity the department
would also be responsible in those cases
to respond to those court appointed
attorneys I'm an attorney by background
even though I'm before you as a
legislative director today and attorneys
do great work but when they are involved
there's going to be additional motions
practice and other issues that will
arise that will require additional
support from our legal team currently
our attorneys are working U very well
they they have uh tremendously good work
ethics but there are guidelines in terms
of case load requirements that they have
and this would be an expansion of that
work based upon the additional attorneys
that we would anticipate being uh
employed to represent the legal interest
of the these children uh currently the
court May appoint as you'll see in the
bill that it works on existing um um
rsas existing law uh but this would
expand it uh to a sha and specific
settings you'll see in the new uh bold
italics uh in the uh language there it
expands it to the scope of children who
are in uh placement uh with the
Department as well as in certified uh
settings as well uh in addition to the
request for the five additional
attorneys and they would be
geographically placed throughout the
state accordingly so they would not just
be centralized they'd be throughout the
state to address the important purpose
of the legislation but also the
additional uh request for the 14 uh
Child Protective Service workers cpsws
who would be needed uh because the bill
does create an additional new
requirement of the department to do a a
very robust assessment in terms of where
that child may be placed to assist our
legal counsil to determine where they
might be placed as well as to provide uh
guidance uh to the uh child in terms of
the amendment to the Bill of Rights of
their right to being informed of their
right to counsel
uh we had some discussions uh when the
bill was before the policy committee
that there has to be some thoughtfulness
and an understanding that the department
acting in that role would be merely
providing very important information but
would not be legally representing the
child at the time that we'd be providing
that information so with that we we do
stand by the Department's analysis we
did it based upon the four corners of
the document in front of us we have been
um uh requested to provide information
as this bill made it through its journey
and and refone you do a wonderful job
talking about the background of the bill
give some context but this is not the
first occasion that we've had to come to
explain why the department provided
information as part of our fiscal
analysis for the LBA to do their
validation of the information that was
provided by the department and I would
like to turn it over to um our um
interim director uh to see if she'd like
sure well the appointment of council
certainly um could lead to more
pleadings in terms of motions um as
referenced um in a child's case it it
also leads to more communication in
general so we would anticipate there's
communication around perhaps things like
visitation U mental health treatment for
the child so that all enhances the um
the workload of the child protective
service workers
um in addition um to as John Williams
said the the contemplation of children
in placement getting ahead of that
notifying the court when um in emergency
situation when there is the need to
place the child residentially so in
addition to the staff attorneys the
cpsws will additionally take on
additional needs and communication and
Outreach um there's also a piece in
there around um providing the attorney
access to to view and copy the child's
records so that would as The Keeper of
the records um the division would have
the child protective service worker um
compiling that information so there are
additional tasks of the cpsws beyond
that which might seem obviously
attorneys so um I guess the the big
question is is there any way it could
hires we don't believe that it
could uh further in the fiscal note in
the methodology it says that the amount
appears insufficient ient to fund all 19
of the new positions which is something
you don't see every day in a fiscal note
uh any comment on that yeah and I think
that Mr Ripple did a very good job
explaining uh the Senate heard our
concerns and there was an Earnest effort
made to providing an appropriation uh
when the bill was in the Senate as it
came to you and it was identified that
the um appropriation that was provided
was only sufficient for the general fund
portion for the five attorneys it did
not include the 14 Child Protective
Service workers uh I I also the other
anomaly with the legislation although it
does provide for a $59,000 and some
change uh general fund appropriation it
it lapses prior to the effective dat of
the bill so the department can't
encumber those funds so this bill is
budget neutral for the the current state
banum but there would be the need for
the resources requested by the
department if this were built into the
budget for 2627 and again I'll turn over
um to um our um interim director um to
her her her thoughts so miss I don't I
don't have anything to add to
that okay representative priest followed
by representative Wier followed by
representative
walner thank you madam chairman um
correct me if I'm wrong is is this going
on in in some capacity right now to
provide legal service for children that
are in need of this uh yes if I can just
uh respond uh the court currently has
the discretion to appoint Council and
and you'll see that in in primarily very
complex cases complex needs for for for
the child I I do know that attorney Erin
krian uh General Council for the digital
branch is also present so she could
certainly elaborate on on those as well
but in addition to current practice for
uh appointment of council the court does
support these children by either
Guardian Liam or CA volunteer or others
who would support them through through
the process um and I would turn to miss
Nunan if she has anything else to
respond to that question sure well while
each situation does have a Caso or gal
appointed it is not a common practice
for the children to also have an
attorney when there's conf conflicts it
certainly is available to the court to
appoint a child and attorney but it is
not a common practice follow up sorry
and I believe it it is reflected in the
fiscal analysis and again referring to
the judicial branch that the numbers
were very small in terms of uh the
current um children in in the past who
have been uh court appointed councel
follow up yes do you have any uh numbers
or statistics that shows how many
children are currently served um with Co
court appointed attorneys and what is
the need for this what is the need for
to having five more additional attorneys
and 18 more social
workers so represent priest thank you
very much for for the question the law
does change the current requirements
currently it's the Court's discretion to
appoint Council and as i' mentioned if
you reflect to the the fiscal analysis
and perhaps uh questions um from the
judicial branch the numbers have been
very small uh and again as I've already
stated in very complex cases complex
needs involving the child if the this
were to be passed there is now a a
default that the child should be
receiving um the support of legal
council and that certainly would be an
increased resource demand to accommodate
the goals of the bill so it would um
allow it uh for an all dependency
proceedings uh proceedings that are
meant to you know provide supports to
the families to uh at least at a minimum
provide um the notice to the child um of
their right to ccel and you can we can
certainly speculate as to the numbers
but it would certainly be much higher
than current the current uh um
discretionary model that we're expecting
that there would be a um a certain
Demand on the um on the department as
well as the courts uh to to accommodate
this new increased access um and again
not commenting on the policy certainly
understand the importance of the
underlying bill but we would need the
resources to be able to accom that i'
ask Miss n please um chime in I'm not
sure that I have anything to add I would
just Echo the additional
responsibilities um the notification to
the child and then the the language
round May um appoint councel in all
cases but shall in the case of
placements so we'll certainly have an
increase in in in workload rightfully so
as a result of the
Bill thank you representative
Wier thank you mam chair are we
replacing casses and and
uh um the other the other group there um
Guardian Ed items no this is not a
replacement this would be in
addition thank you representative walner
thank you so I'm still trying to get my
head
around this is going to probably at any
one time affect about 120
children well I think we have about 300
children in placement and in residential
so all of th those children would
receive appointed counsel and then the
other children that we serve as well may
also be appointed um because we will
notify them as their right and they may
request that so they may also be
appointed
councel they all now have a case worker
they do so would you how would you how
would you use the additional 14 would
you reduce case load
for the
existing um protective workers we
wouldn't see it as a reduction we'd see
it as maintaining the current number of
children and families that they're
working with um but each each area would
receive each district office would
receive an additional cpsw to manage to
manage that um in addition to the larger
offices would would receive
two and with the new 14 social workers
they would also they would carry a case
load correct is that correct yes they
would so it would reduce the case load
of the other
existing I understand your question yes
yes it would allow for the increased
work um we we talk about case load and
workload so we may see a slight
reduction in a case load but the
increase thank you
representative Lyon um thank you madam
chairman
um I just want to clarify so this would
be adding an attorney um appointed for
the child on top of a cat Casa and on
top of a guardian at letum that's
correct that is a that is a very good
question this does not include the cost
for the actual attorney that would be
appointed uh we're speaking on behalf of
the department clearly that's our area
that we're providing our financial uh
analysis or impact um on this there will
be others who might be able to comment
on the cost for the the attorney and I
and I do think that the fiscal analysis
was very well done by Mr Ripple and
actually gives you at least uh kind of
the the landscape of what that cost may
be per attorney thank you representative
hle thank you madam chair um thank you
for pointing out that the this does not
include the costs for the judicial side
of the equation and I see the fiscal
note doesn't say that um Mr Ripple can
you see if you can get a number from an
estimate from them yes I can thank you
so um on lines 12 through 14 on page
three relative to the positions again
these are starting at step five
positions for both the attorneys as well
as the cpsws is there a rationale for
that so in regard to the cpsws um we
we're able to hire at steps 1 through
four um depending on the experience and
the qualifications of the candidates
before us and so we always strive to
hire the most capable competent um
experienced educated staff that we're
able to and our hope would be that um
you know we would be able to find those
candidates additionally
um we we're finding we're having
candidates coming with uh more
experience uh more life experienced um
it's less frequent that we're finding um
out of college you know fresh out of
college um candidates and so we're
needing to be um a Workforce that
attracts our seasoned experienced um
potential Workforce and so we need to
have the levels one through four
available for
hiring and and can you speak to the
staff Attorneys at level two again step
five I think it would be the same it
would be the same in terms of I can't
speak to whether we're getting more
seasoned um experienced attorneys but
we're capable of hiring up through our
top level of attorney and we would want
to have that available um in these
instances as well
so is there any intent to promote within
the department to these higher level
positions and then
backfill no that would not be Our
intention okay uh one last question
right now who advocates for the child in
the in this process today so currently
each child is uh appointed a guardian
edl or aasa and those are the entities
that currently advocate for the best
interests of the
child okay versus best expressed
interests versus the child's expressed
interests yes thank
you thank you anything further okay
we're all set oh representative walner
thank you so almost every time we come
in this room we talk about reducing the
number of children who are in
residential placement
and I know the department has a lot of
initiatives to uh work on that and to
reduce them what what do you see in the
near
future of how many children do you think
we might be able to bring back into the
community and to Foster families and fam
their kin um because as as we bring
those children back into those
settings this this won't be as necessary
there won't be as many of these children
sure one yeah that's true um and it
would eliminate the shell but not
necessarily the May in terms of children
that may Express an interest to have an
attorney so that that is a true
statement um I would be hesitant to
provide a number of of children that
we're actively working on but I can
share with you that we are certainly
looking at ensuring that our community
based care is expanded is stood up um
has the workforce that it needs to be
able to provide the preventative
Services to prevent children from being
in residential treatment to begin with
um so we've got lots of efforts in the
preventative realm as well as looking at
our current service array to ensure that
if we were to step children down from
residential treatment to Community Based
care that we have an array of services
available for
you okay thank you both very much thank
you anyone else yes please please come
forward and state your name and your
believe honorable chair oh your
microphone didn't quite
click there you go red okay um good
afternoon honorable chair and members of
the committee my name is Michelle
wangren I'm an attorney at New Hampshire
legal assistance and director of the
youth law project there um so I have
worked on this bill for for quite a long
time there is actually um two sort of
parallel bills I know representative
Hull had brought an initial right to
counsel bill that was interim studied La
the year before last and um the child
and family law committee did a lot of
work on that bill tried to explore ways
to bring down the fiscal note to Target
uh Council for kids to um abuse and
neglect cases I believe that Bill had
had initially had an expanded right to
all family cases so this this one does
narrow that field um and we did a lot of
work in child and family law this where
535 ended up passing out of committee um
I think it was 14 to1 there was there
was one um opposition and then um and
then SB 463 is sort of the parallel View
and The Advocates that have worked on
this Initiative for years really see
this as um an even improved version of
that bill it really brings in sort of
the interplay between attorneys and
Casas which we think is um important to
really outline the role caas and sort of
the the value added of attorneys without
minimizing that role so we think that
that initial Preamble is really
important in this bill um and then it
also adds some clarification around the
language of when council is appointed so
we really think that this is a gold
standard bill it passed out of um the
Senate policy committee I believe
unanimously um same thing here in the
house we think that this has been well
vetted in terms of the policy and we're
really excited about this opportunity um
a couple things that it does is it
brings New Hampshire in line with some
national nationally recognized best
practices currently New Hampshire is
only one of 13 states in the country
that don't guarantee a child a right to
express interest counsel and it's only
one of six C Six States in the country
that never guarantees a child a right to
counsel currently in New Hampshire um
children only are able to have counsel
if they have an Express disagreement
with their um with their CA so their
their best interest advocate in the
court system so if they have a
disagreement with their CA and the ca
brings that to the court the court then
may appoint an attorney there is
absolutely no provision in law that will
ever guarantee a right to children in
these proceedings an attorney yet what
we know is that there are currently 124
youth um in abuse and neglect cases um
according to information just provided
by the off Office of the child advocate
who are currently in institutional
settings um removed not just from their
families um not just from their
communities but are placed in
institutions in group care where they
are with staff not families that love
them not families that could love them
someday and care for them forever but in
institutional settings which is akin to
where kids who have been charged with
delinquency k delinquent in delinquency
cases and are institutionalized are
placed these are children who have not
committed crimes but who have been
abused by their families and there have
been findings of abuse against them and
they are in institutional settings so
throughout the years we've been working
on this bill we really try to narrow in
on that population of Youth to ensure
that those kids who are the most in need
are targeted for these limited resources
that we know the state has we think best
practice would be to provide all youth
in care um the right to an attorney but
that's not what this bill does because
we attempted to very narrowly Target it
to use our resources as well um so it
does two things it allows um judges in
complicated cases to appoint Council to
kids if they deem it necessary so it
expands the discretionary right to
counsel to not just um allow Court to
appoint counsel if there's a
disagreement between a child and their
Casa um at the dispositional hearing so
there's also that temporal Lim
limitation currently but if there's a
particularly complex case where a where
a judge believes that a child could
benefit from counsil it it gives the
judge that Latitude to do that we think
that that probably could happen in a um
in a narrow category of cases I know
that I've been I'm an attorney who rep
who um represents kids in a variety of
different settings um and I've been um
contacted by Casas who really believe
that a child could benefit from
additional legal support and they just
don't feel like they have that support
um they there are attorneys within the
office um that that you know that's
limited they can't do it in every single
case and so this would when those
attorneys aren't available it would give
the judge the latitude to do that that's
what I'm trying to say um the second
category of children who would be enti
to counsel are children who are either
in or at risk of institutional placement
and we like this bill because it defines
very clearly what it means for a child
to be at risk of institutional placement
I think you heard from the Department
just now that one of the additional
duties that would be imposed on Child
Protection soal protective social
workers is to provide an assessment to
determine when a child requires
placement but what's confusing I think
about that representation is that
there's already a very robust process in
place to determine when a child is at
risk of institutional placement So
currently um under the family's First
Act and then written into dcyf policy
when DCF is recommending a child for
institutional or group CARE um they have
to refer a child to what's called a cat
assessment it's a comprehensive
assessment for treatment and that cat
assessment then assesses the child it
communicates with the family it
communicates with the social workers and
it might communicate with providers to
determine what level of care a child
needs so what this bill is it ties the
atrisk determination to that process
that already exists it does not add
another layer of assessment it a it says
L quite literally that when a CH when
when dcyf either sends a packet of
information to an Institutional setting
or refers the child for a cat assessment
the child is then deemed at risk and
they must simply notify the court um
that that they have initiated that
process and that the child should be
appointed an attorney we do not think
that that would require one cpsw much
less
14 um the the second uh the the second
piece that I heard that that DCF may
need to do is inform the child of their
right um to council but what this bill
does it is it just adds it to one of
many rights within the Foster youth Bill
of Rights so when a child is removed
from their home and only when a child is
removed from their home um they must be
read the the Foster youth Bill of Rights
and they must be informed of their
rights and how to exercise those rights
I think there are 23 rights um including
you know the right to familial
Association the right to continue
contact with their siblings just many
good rights so in that form that is
already provided to the child they will
have to do they will have to include one
additional right that is they have the
right to have councel if they are in an
Institutional placement or referred to
an Institutional placement um or they
have a right to request councel and then
it must just say set forth um the
process for doing so so if DCF or the
courts or whoever determines that the
process to request councel is to write a
letter to the court it just says you can
request Council by writing a letter to
the court so it require this bill
requires nothing more than that to tell
tell the child they have a right to
request counsel and how to do that again
we don't think that requires one cpsw
much less 14
cpsws um in terms of the additional
workload placed upon um dcyf lawyers if
there are additional
counsel of course I'm a lawyer that
could happen um that is that could be
real whether they need five I don't know
the original fiscal note for this Bill
did have um the fiscal note for the five
attorneys you know if if that's
something that this committee is is um
willing to look at I think that that
might you know they may need that I
think that even that number is inflated
but what I'm so worried about with this
bill is I think it is yet another really
really strong policy that has been well
vetted um narrowly tailored and is at
risk of not passing Finance because of
what we believe is a incredibly INF
inflated fiscal note not now not for
this session because there is no fiscal
impact this session um but in the future
and so what we what we kind of like
about how the fiscal Noe is working
right now is that um we think that the
policy should pass and a lot of these
issues could then play out through the
budget process um and and and I think
there would be time to do that to really
V you know what of of these bills that
involve dcy which ones do pass and what
of these responsibilities and these um
requests that they're asking for could
be combined and we think that that's
something that could be done in the next
bium but wouldn't want good policy not
to pass because there's a question about
how big the the fiscal note could be
down the road um when we just don't
think there are there's there are duties
in the bill that that require that level
of work on the Department's side one
thing I did do is I the fiscal note for
on the judicial Council side um
indicated that of the very few attorneys
that have been appointed in these cases
the average cost um per case is $
1,02
$12 so I just did some math so I know
from the from the office of the child
advocate that um currently there are1
1224 kids in care so um in institutional
placements so say we double that and get
I don't know 250 and say because we know
that there's going to be a frontload of
attorneys and then kids will trickle in
throughout the year so we double that we
add a little bit say 300 so say there's
300 kids over the course of the year who
need counsel uh if we take the average
cost per case right now of what the
judicial council is paying that's
3,600 for the council for the children
and yet what we have is a fiscal note
for the Department two years down the
road that's 1 million5
$500,000 as opposed to the cost of
council for kids roughly
$300,000 that's concerning this is good
policy that is at risk because of an
inflated fiscal note this is the fiscal
committee I'm happy to answer any policy
questions I've thought about this a lot
through the years but please focus on
the reasonable a reasonable fiscal note
and ask questions of the department
these questions of the department which
I know the committee has been doing but
I encourage you to continue committing
and not let this fiscal note kill good
policy happy to ask answer any
questions thank you for that any
questions or
comments okay I think we're all set but
thank you very much thank you I think an
amendment will likely be proposed on
this
bill um is someone going to request that
or um I
could um start drafting it
representative
priest
good I think there's enough to go on
there to craft an amendment uh anyone
else on Senate Bill 463 yes from the
hello Aon krian general counsel for the
judicial branch uh to your financial
question we did complete a fiscal note
on HB uh 535 which is the house
companion uh so I compliment the house
on having asked us for a fiscal note uh
it's too bad that the Senate was not as
diligent as Mr Ripple uh but but it it
was relatively low uh it's a little
difficult to estimate for us the cost
because we are having these hearings and
these proceedings already presumably the
attorney is going to increase the time
because that's what they're there to do
they're there to bring additional
arguments on behalf of the child so our
estimate was in each of these let's say
about 130 cases that if it was only
about a half hour of additional
arguments a year that might be low but
let's just say that it was about $40,000
in cost I wouldn't there probably are
some additional costs you're
rescheduling because of attorneys you
have longer arguments but the costs are
not as high for us as they probably are
for the judicial Council I don't believe
anyone from judicial Council made it so
I I will say uh that the the previous
witness is is probably right in her
estimate they they provided a very good
um write up for the fiscal note on how
they estimate the cost and I think it it
probably would be somewhere around
$300,000 if I'm guessing so between us
and them maybe
$350,000 or
so one thing I did put in that fiscal
note on on HB uh 535 which is not a
strictly a fiscal question but a
question that potentially increased
costs and and is one question that has
been a little open-ended for us is this
bill and HP 535 have progressed which is
that um we we do have a shortage of
attorneys in New Hampshire unfortunately
uh there are many Creative Solutions
that we've come up with uh we have
police prosecutors or are sometimes non-
attorneys we have a par professional
program which is being reauthorized
where um par professionals can represent
people in court in certain cases uh the
the pools of attorneys that potentially
we would draw on for these mandatory
appointments are potentially those that
are representing children in delinquency
cases and those that are representing
parents in their mandatory appointment
cases such as abuse and neglect and
termination cases those pools are very
small they're very thin we're getting
very close to situations where we don't
have someone someday for for our
existing statutory obligations and I
know that there is a very committed
group of Advocates many of them here in
the room that are working on bringing
new people into the fold to take these
appointments particularly for children
and that it is all of our strong hope
that um should this mandatory
appointment uh come to pass that we have
the attorneys to fulfill it but I have
certainly had judges ask me what they
should do if there isn't an attorney
available and I think I know what would
happen which is there'd be delay and
there'd be upset in the case and then
eventually they'd have to proceed um but
if the legislature is envisioning a
different uh result in that case it
would just be helpful to have that
guidance because the judges would prefer
to do what you have determined is the
right thing to do in that situation
rather than ad hoc potentially different
and potentially not what you were
intending to have happen in that
circumstance so that is the only
implementation question that I have as I
read the bill otherwise it is a policy
judgment and we have the ability to
implement
it thank you very much any thoughts or
questions okay all helpful information
for the priest amendment that we all
look forward to seeing
thank you anything further Senate Bill
yes Miss
masso that was very close maio maio very
good Lista masio associate child
advocate um I just want to say how
strongly the office of child advocate
supports this bill we have also been
part of uh those working groups that
attorney wangerin mentioned starting
last fall on children and family working
all through this session um we have been
CL collaborating with The Advocates with
the Department with the
Judiciary this bill um does relate in
part to our bledo uh report that I've
spoken about the two children there in
Tennessee did not have
attorneys the outcome may have been
better for them had they had attorneys
um as far as I'll go backwards as far as
implementation um I do sit on a number
of other committees and working groups
they are recruiting more attorneys both
for parent par and with the anticipation
that these children's attorneys are
coming both because of the legislation
that's been pending but also the
judicial Council just a week or so ago
approved standards for children's
attorneys which has been a work in
progress for a couple of years so the
judicial branch at least is anticipating
this is happening they've created
standards um Lisa Wilford who I I don't
believe could make it today she is the
executive director of the children's Law
Center a nonprofit that provides Council
for children in a variety of these cases
has been working closely with a number
of people including the judicial Council
and model Court to create trainings for
children's attorneys um as I mentioned
earlier I was a parent attorney for many
years when I was in private practice it
is a thin pool but it's a growing pool
and those that serve in that pool are
extremely dedicated I have no doubt that
the people that serve as parents
attorneys may also pick up children's
cases I can tell you when I was a
parents attorney I was living in The
Lakes Region I I would drive to Berlin
to Littleton to Keane to take cases this
is a pool of people that are very
dedicated and I have no doubt that um
folks who want to help children who are
currently helping children in the
Juvenile Justice Arena and other Arenas
would happily Step Up um I would support
everything that attorney wangerin said
as far as the questions about Staffing
uh that you chairwoman Mooney asked they
do seem a little out of line with what
is required in this bill um
there's always balancing of workloads
and case loads um nothing in this bill
appears to create a massive amount of
work for
cpsws I can tell you as a parent
attorney I filed maybe three motions um
there's not a ton of motion practice in
this area much of what happens happens
at the existing hearings they are
happening every three months it's not
like it's going a year um so a lot of
the work happens right at a hearing um
you know is some minor motions practice
but generally you know I don't believe
it would add a ton of attorney time for
dcyf it's already an ongoing case um as
far as the records that Miss Nunan
mentioned this does give a right to a
newly appointed children's attorney to
view and copy um there already is a
pretty robust uh Discovery process in
DCF cases the attorneys are actually
involved in that process you know there
are case
AIDS unfortunately there's actually not
a ton of paperwork around children in
these cases there's not probably a lot
of paperwork involved but would it
include 14
cpsws probably not there are case AIDS
and lower level folks that already exist
that could help with copying records if
necessary um but generally the policy
here is strong um as mentioned this has
been very narrowly tailored it is a
population currently of only about 124
kids that are in open child protection
cases that are in residential placement
the other number of children that I
Believe Miss Nan mentioned child uh
Juvenile Justice kids already have
attorneys so the other out of that group
already have attorneys appointed to them
it's only the child protection kids that
do not have an attorney um so generally
speaking this this bill has really been
worked on for a very long time with an
outcome that I think is is very narrow
but helps a very vulnerable population
of children that are don't have a lot of
independent eyes on them that do are you
know separated from their families and
their communities and you know the
office of child advocate spends a bit of
our time visiting these kids in
residential placements both in New
Hampshire in New England and even
traveling out of state to to visit kids
like the kids at bledo in Tennessee and
these are some of our most vulnerable
children and they need as many voices as
possible nakasa is an important voice um
they're also Limited in what they can do
and uh they are not attorneys they are
not filing motions normally they are
representing what they believe is in
that child's best interest they are not
representing that child's expressed
interest so I'm happy to take any
questions uh we do feel like this is
really important policy to move forward
the other important policies we've
talked about today of keeping children
with their families in their communities
limiting that residential placement
short as time as possible as narrow as
possible and attorneys can help in that
I
believe thank you any questions or
comments from Miss massio thank you
thank you a lot of good stuff definitely
in this bill but uh I do believe this
has to be straightened out here with
4 section four in
particular okay anything further
all right we're going to move from
that we have two bills left in this work
session today um it's about five minutes
to 4 I'm okay to stay and take them both
up does anyone have any thoughts or
objections to that
okay
567 an act directing the commissioner of
the Department of Health and Human
Services to compile a report on the
availability of mif prone and miso
bill came out of Senate Judiciary
3-2 came out of the Senate on an ought
to pass with Amendment on a Voice
vote went to Health and Human Services
in the house came out with a vote of 10
to six and then out of the Full House by
only a TW vote margin 184 to
182 anybody here to remark on Senate
Bill 567 thank you and if you could just
um again reintroduce yourself and also
uh make sure your microphone is on and
while I'm thinking about it I just want
to thank representative Wier for doing
this m Major League Marathon session as
our backup substitute Clerk and there
yes thank you representative wer very
much appreciated leaving in 35 minutes
there you go and there were times he had
to leave the room so we actually had a
backup clerk to the backup Clerk and
that was representative Lon at times so
thank you very much for your
contribution as well thank you and
welcome to division three thank you so
much my name is Patricia Tilly I'm an
associate commissioner at the Department
of Health and Human Services hopefully I
will help you make up some time um we
just have a few comments on this bill
excuse me t i l l y thank you you're
welcome so this bill places the
department in a pickle is the uh
technical term I will use for this it
directs the department to step outside
of its current role to address what
actions would be needed to be put in
place to protect and expand access to
these medications that the department
does not control on top of that it
states that no General funds and no
existing federal funds appropriated the
department can be used to meet the
requirements of the bill or I I'll
reframe that no General funds and does
not specify around federal funds it
directs the department to seek or apply
for um the appropriate grants or federal
funds um to complete the report but we
know of No Such funding source that
would could be used for this purpose um
I will also note that even if we did
know of a potential funding source it's
unclear just technically if we could get
those funds um included within our
budget through our joint legislative
fiscal committee as well as governor and
councel given the topic um it's
important to note that the department
does not collect any data at this time
regarding abortion or abortion
medications um and many of our federal
fund funding sources such as the title
10 Family Planning program limits the
Department's capacity to even address
issues of abortion um so I will stop
there I'm happy to take questions the
department the bill requires the
department to write a report for things
that we don't typically manage and it's
unclear the funding source we would use
to do that thank you uh just to draw
your attention to the fiscal note we are
looking and working off of the fiscal
note dated April 2nd 2024 and it looks
like um a total fiscal impact of less
than $10,000 that's from General
funds that's correct and that was
um based on a conversation I had with
the Department stating that the Bill's
requirements would uh reflect
approximately 5% of the cost of a
full-time equivalent position so that's
how we arrived at the under 10k
figure okay and I notice it does not
appear on the appropriation bills list
so just to draw the attention there okay
we're going to go representative priest
representative hle representative
Leon thank you Madame chairman for
taking my question and thank you for
being here
um currently you are not doing this is
that correct that is correct and is the
act or the the value of the individual's
privacy a big factor of why you're not
doing this if you are asking as to why
we are not collecting abortion related
data privacy is certainly Paramount and
that has been a a question that has been
considered by the general court quite
frankly for more than a decade I've been
around a long time and pretty much every
bium we have a conversation around
abortion related statistics privacy is
always an issue cost is always an
issue followup as a followup the cost is
very minimal and so I would say privacy
in the fact
that there really isn't a need to to get
this
information to have this
information I'm not sure if there's a
question there I there isn't I guess you
thank you representative hle thank you
madam chair are you doing something
similar for any other um either off the
shelf or prescription medication this
type of repor this this is a great
question I mean so if we were to compare
this to say Di IES medicine we if we
knew that there were medications that
vulnerable populations were not able to
access that would that might be
something that we would be interested in
doing and quite frankly we would
probably have a federal funding source
whether it is through Medicaid or
through some Hera or CDC funds that we
would be able to explore that idea the
these particular medications as I said
just put us in a pickle because we are
typically not in the business of
providing them thank you represent ative
tarki thank you I was just um the
comments about privacy I don't actually
see how that pertains to this bill at
all um it correct it I was responding to
why we don't collect abortion statistics
in terms of privacy for this bill this
is a policy question around access and
um barriers to access for two particular
medications okay and so there would not
be necessarily a privacy issue here but
again the pickle that we are in is that
we don't have a particular uh program
that would be funded to do this we don't
have a particular um uh funding source
that would do it and it's outside the
scope of what we typically do as Mr
Ripple noted it's not a heavy lift it
just puts us in a pickle to figure out
how to do that representative Lon then
representative priest then
representative walner um thank you madam
chair um in testimony in the Health and
Human Services committee there was some
discussion about how if the FDA approval
was reversed um like we've seen with
some cold medicines how the state would
ensure access to this um my question is
if the department is in the business of
um providing access to medications that
are not um permitted under the FDA
typically not I I think that would be
the answer I mean we would look at
through um again if I were to talk about
diabetes medication or hypertension
medication we would want to ensure that
care is getting to um patients
especially within the Medicaid
population or low in or vulnerable
populations that we typically have
public health concerns around a
follow-up question followup um as a
followup if the FDA um was um stopped
allowing access to these or any other
medications would it put the department
in a difficult position of trying to go
against federal policy um by a mandate
from the state um thank you for that
question you know I would have to think
about that a little more the way that I
read this is really a report about
access and how we would do Outreach and
um address barriers so I don't know that
we would be in a particular uh where
that would Place Us in terms of FDA I
think we would simply need to state that
if the FDA took away um their approval
for this you know it would mean XYZ for
the population thank you representative
priest then representative walner thank
you madam chairman and thank you for
taking my question what programs do you
currently have in providing
uh women um with limited
income information about birth control
Health
practices availability to this
medication sure thank you so I will take
that in two parts you asked uh initially
what programs does the department have
around reproductive Health generally I
I'll I'll sum Summit that way well we
have our family planning program which
is a federally funded title 10 we use
some general funds to provide family
planning which is really focused on
reproductive Health primary care
preventative care and contraception it
does not include abortion um our family
planning program does not pay for
abortion we are federally and we have
both federal and state law that um
prohibits abortion as a part of that
program it is a Comprehensive Health
women representative
walner thank you
if um if there was an appropriation on
this particular piece of
legislation is it possible for the
Department to contract out the writing
of and the developing of this report so
it wouldn't fall to the
department sure I I that's certainly
something we would likely consider again
there are some probably things we would
have to think about at the end of the
day um the political considerations of
that if that contract um would be
supported by um the executive Council
but that would be a mechanism that we
could think about using in order to
complete uh the requirements of of this
reporting followup can you think do
you can you think of any contractors
that might be available to do this kind
of work there certainly could be you
know I think there are Health policy um
you know vendors out there who could do
that or academic folks that might be
interested there certainly probably are
um a population of appropriate folks
that could write this thank
you representative tarki thank you I
guess I just W to get a clarification on
something um it's my understanding these
drugs are not used solely for
abortions but are also used in cases of
medical crisis where a pregnancy
um fails yes
um would there be any benefit
to doing what is um in this bill to
ensure that the medication is still
available in those
situations thank you that's a great
question and I think we would highlight
that in any report they are primarily
used for early term abortion right now
but that is not the sole reason that
those these um particular ular
medications are used and are authorized
for use there are even things Beyond
termination or even looking at at
somehow um if you have a a pregnancy
that is in trouble um so there are other
areas in which these medications are
used I think it's probably the safest
way to answer your question that well
that's what I was saying so I guess
throwing out the you know the baby with
the bath water in terms of you know we
you don't address that issue I guess I'm
just wondering the medical um you know
use of these drugs sure and I I don't
know the prevalence of how they're used
I mean that's one of the things we don't
collect data on right now so I don't
know the prevalence to say how you know
what big of an impact that would be in
the state of New Hampshire I certainly
know from the medical I'm not a
clinician but I certainly know from the
medical literature that these
medications are used for other purposes
and so that would be of interest in a
sort of General Public Health um
sentiment of can folks get access to
them but T again typically this is not
the type of report that the department
gets asked to be to complete very
helpful information thank you Miss Tilly
anything else from Members okay thank
you thank
you anyone else here to remark on Senate
Bill
today Senate
Bill 596
oh oh on the previous one okay thank you
why don't you uh come forward and
introduce
567 and a special thank you to
representative Steph Boyd for uh being
with us today and um we appreciate your
time and attention thank you very
much okay please introduce yourself and
onward we go
thank you madam chair my name is Jason
Hennessy I'm the president for New
Hampshire right to life I'm here to
represent our many members who are on
the prif side I also have some
experience in research and have a PhD in
computational sciences and
statistics uh I I provided some written
testimony that has a lot of this I've
also emailed it to the members that were
on the
roster and I wanted to express four
reasons why I suggest that you vote itl
on this bill the first one is that uh
this is an infr on the free market if
you look in the bill it has it it wants
to study things like increase Outreach
in education and protect and expand
access these are things that are already
done in the private sector and which
should be handled by the free market
especially for something so
controversial in our society where 70%
of New Hampshire residents believe that
there should be some sort of
restrictions on abortion our nation's
largest pharmacy CVS and and and as well
as Walgreens and others have already
announced their commitment to to
abortion pills we should let them take
care of the logistics and advertising
for their product instead of having
taxpayers subsidize their business
interests um despite this being a small
a small outlay the principle is
important the second one is that this is
a solution to an unknown problem um the
only threat that's been pointed out is
the US Supreme Court and unless we're
planning to challenge Federal Supremacy
I don't know what the state of New
Hampshire would do about that and I
think challenging that would cost a lot
um third I I'd like to ask why is this
the priority I mean we would prefer that
there be no Financial restrictions I
mean that would be a great world to live
in but that's not the world we live in
we live in a world with restrictions so
are so what I haven't heard discussed is
what wouldn't be done as a result of
passing this bill because there is much
um HHS I I just looked at the website
this morning has 85 openings which means
there's many things that they can't do
now due to staff
shortages so the question is what would
they be giving up in order to do this
study I mean this is this is a big
question um I I I found three examples
just from the past two months of of big
deals uh in in healthcare in New
Hampshire for instance uh Nationwide the
current FDA currently lists 112 drugs in
shortage 15 of which are oncology uh
drugs and there's people who are dying
from these New Hampshire is facing a
nursing shortage with the most nursing
openings per capita of any New England
State and in March of this year New
Hampshire had 129 patients who could
have been discharged but weren't because
of various reasons there were some that
even had to stay in hospitals for over
days but they didn't need to be there
these I would say that these are
probably uh more worth of our more
worthy of our
attention I also point out that house
hhsa in a bipartisan vote of 10 to six
said that this was not a priority at
least that's the way I interpret it
although the vice chair is here and she
could she could uh explain that much
better than I'm sure I
could and finally uh increasing access
to abortion medications would also
increase the danger to New Hampshire
pregnant women both from forced or
coerced abortions as well as from signif
the significant health risks that come
from the abortion pill I've included
evidence in my in my written U my
written testimony of the ex ex of the
dangers to pregnant mothers um as well
as for its documented use to abuse women
by giving the pill to them unknowingly
this is just bad policy and that's my
testimony and I I would be happy to take
any
questions thank you Mr Hennessy any
questions or
comments okay seeing none thank you very
much thank you madam
chair all right last call now on Senate
Bill
567 okay any further thoughts as we go
forward all right
we will take up then our last bill of
the
day and that is Senate Bill
596 this is an act relative to the
definition of disability or special
program by means of some background here
this
bill started in Senate education with an
study it was then removed from consent
calendar and voted ought to pass on a
Voice
vote it then went to the Senate finance
Zer then came from to the U House
Education committee 11
to9 and then out of the house with a
170 let's go to the fiscal note I see we
have a revised fiscal note dated May 6th
that is the most
recent the amount here looks like
372,000 in fiscal year
2025 followed by 744 th000 in both
fiscal years 2026 and
2027 anything further on that Mr
Ripple I would only call your attention
to the source of fund funds so as with a
previous bill in this committee you'll
notice that the appropriation with the
exception of $1 is Federal arpa or other
federal funds and it includes language
up on lines 5 through 7 allowing the
department to suspend implementation if
insufficient okay thank you so this does
have an arpa might as well jump right to
I see on the first page of the bill
assuming every assuming everybody has
the first page of the bill they do uh on
starting on line
25 that's right arpa or other federal
funds if available okay anyone here to
hello thank you uh my name is Brian
Clark I'm the general counsel for the
division of economic
stability uh so Senate Bill 596 what it
would do is give the department the
authority to adopt rules to expand um
the protected class in um the New
Hampshire Child Care scholarship program
so the New Hampshire Child Care
scholarship program as I testified
before is a program that provides child
care subsidies to low-income individuals
who participate in qualifying activities
um so what we do currently is that for
for kids that are eligible for child
care scholarship if they have particular
special
needs um such as
disabilities that have been diagnosed we
could pay what is called a differential
to the child care provider which is just
an increase to the payment
to recognize that the kid with special
needs might take a little more staff
time um and so it kind of incentivizes
taking those individual children um and
so what the sponsors of the legislation
were trying to fix is kids who are at
risk of or experiencing social or
emotional developmental
delays um who are young very young um
and are likely have
issues um potentially like autism
spectrum disorder uh but they're waiting
to get a diagnosis because the waight
list to see a specialist who can make
the diagnosis is sometimes years
long so what the bill was seeking to do
and and what the department would do
through rulemaking is allow screening
tools instead of an official diagnosis
to determine uh that a child has
significant special needs um and then be
payment okay so thank you for that um in
on page
one line 13 through
15 uh there
is a definition of disability or special
needs under the child care scholarship
program and shall include any child who
displays or is at risk for delayed
social or emotional development is there
a definition of delayed social or
emotional development in
writing uh so we would need to develop
that and it would be based on the
specific uh clinical tool we select so
the clinical tool would measure whether
that exists whether the social or
emotional it would have to be signed by
a approved by a
um okay thank you representative Lyon um
thank you madam chair um are there any
of these existing screening tools and
can that information be provided because
it seems kind of without a specific tool
and without naming a tool this seems a
little
broad so this what this version of the
leg islation was um the result of a
compromise between uh the the department
and uh Advocates um the department would
like to see select screening tools that
that we designate so that we don't have
tools as a followup would it be possible
to know what some of those tools are or
to at least have that information sent
to us because I don't know if we'll be
able to adjust digest it at the moment
anyways okay uh well I know that um in
earlier versions of uh the the initial
introduced version had those tools
listed uh what we' like to do is through
Ru making specifically identify which
one we would like to be used so that we
don't have to train on all of
sense it sort of makes sense except that
the r making should follow the statutory
guidance
um so I think it would be a lot cleaner
to look at what we're actually looking
but okay anything
further all right thank you very much
once again you were here earlier today
yes yeah once again you're taking on the
role of it seems sponsor and explainer
and for your department and everything
is the first one to testify so I truly
appreciate uh your ability to come
forward and handle all these questions
that would otherwise likely given to the
sponsor of the Bill thank you very much
596 thank you madam chair honorable
members of the committee um my name is
Michelle Merritt I'm the president at
new Futures I'm going to be brief and
I'm going to turn it over to my
colleague um I wanted to take a moment
to explain sort of um some of the
procedural things that happened with
this bill I think unfortunately before
it got to you um so the bill was
introduced by Senator Rashard in the
Senate and passed through the Senate
without incident um when it crossed over
to the house unfortunately I think that
there was um some uh I don't necessarily
want to say error but it was assigned to
the education committee when it's a DHHS
um particular program um and our
experience with the education committee
was um that when it was being discussed
in that committee there was not a lot of
understanding of what the child care
scholarship program was and the special
committee on child care and speaking
with the chairman did not have an
opportunity because it was a second
committee Bill to take it into the
special committee on Child Care um so it
wasn't up for an inter it was a a debate
between an interim study and a um ought
to pass in that particular committee um
and we were working really hard with the
committee but they had lingering
questions we didn't have enough time to
answer so um that just explains a little
bit about why we think it encountered a
hiccup um in that particular committee
because it really was a DHHS item um so
I thought that history might be a little
bit in Illuminating for some of
you go ahead thanks um my name is
Rebecca vo kovsky and I'm the child and
family policy director at new Futures so
I'll just Begin by saying that um we've
been bringing together a group of early
care and education providers over the
past 2 years and one of the number one
concerns um for these providers has been
around capacity of teachers and centers
to take in kids who have more
challenging um behavioral needs but do
not have a formal diagnosis of special
needs or disability um this bill would
really be essential for child care
centers to be able to maintain the
number of slots they have and take in
more kids as well as support their
teaching staff I want to emphasize that
this bill um provides a differential but
it doesn't provide a treatment for a
child that was a confusion in um House
Education this is about supporting and
strengthening Child Care Centers I also
want to indicate that this bill does not
create new screenings for children
children are being um having
developmental screening on a regular
basis through their child care center or
their um pediatrician this just creates
a pathway for those kids um to be able
to enter a child care setting and that
child care center to be prepared to take
care of them
um we do know that some Child Care
Centers unfortunately are using
developmental screenings to root out
children that may have more complex
needs because they can't take them in so
essentially what we don't want to create
is a system where children who have more
complex needs can't access child care I
also want to emphasize that this child
care differential would not just be
available to center-based care but again
because it is in our child care
development block grant this would be
available to our inhome providers our um
Center based providers and others to
answer your question um representative
Leon in the first version of the bill
Advocates did outline the um standard
Early Childhood screenings that could be
used but I'll happily provide those to
you offline I also want to indicate that
Advocates do have some question on the
Appropriations that are listed for
future years childcare advisory reported
on the expenditures in this line of C
CDF and to date it has only been
$558,000 this year so we think that a
more modest um future fiscal note is
probably more likely and I will say that
you can tell there's been a downward
Trend so this definition of disability
is so narrow that kids and families are
not able to access or not be childcare
centers can't access this differential
and it is creating a um barrier to
access for our kids that have more
representative Lyon followed by
representative priest um thank you um it
almost seems like a gem of the testimony
just came out with that if they're using
these screening tests to keep kids out
of the child care centers wouldn't that
just be priority number one to not allow
them to screen them out with it I'm not
sure why that wasn't the bill well um I
think that it's a bit unspoken yes it's
unspoken so it's one of those things
where Child Care Centers say that they
don't have the capacity to take kids
because we don't pay our early care and
education um providers to necessarily
train their staff um we have a child
care crisis so we don't have the
adequate number of sta Staffing that we
need um and I don't know that there's
precedent in this state where the state
legislature can um or has passed a
Prohibition on screening children for um
developmental issues and then
prohibiting that with regards to child
care I think that our childcare Market
would um against that representative
Leon and as a followup do those
screenings require parental consent yes
they do the ages and stages
questionnaire which I will provide to
you after is both a parent and provider
screening um important to note too that
many children who are screened to
qualify for services you have to be 33
and
1/3% um delayed for state level Services
if you fall below that um if you don't
meet that amount then your private
insurance has to cover um but it also
doesn't lead to a formal diagnosis so
there's this whole gray area where kids
need access to additional services but
can't get them um I would also say that
you know it is in our best interest to
ensure that kids have access to high
quality um centers whether that's in
home faith-based or in Center based
because it saves money in the long
term so the only thing that I'll add um
to Rebecca's uh answer to the question
is one of the experiences that we've
seen is that child care centers who have
children with that fall into this
category um in order to be able to serve
them they have to artificially
suppressed ratios um or not serve them
and open up those slots to other kids so
it is getting at that uh by addressing
this issue is making sure that the
centers have enough funds available to
them to appropriately manage those kids
in those classes so they don't have to
be put in that catch22 situation um
which is an important Point
representative
PRI thank you Madame chairman for taking
my question and thank you for being here
uh again uh on the fiscal note uh I
would like to have you um restate what
you think would be a realistic cost
given what you're seeing now as special
needs children in um Child Care
Facilities what I'd like to do is send
you what was presented to a childcare
advisory on the recent drawdowns um it
shows what has been expended in this
line over um the past three years and at
the height it has um been about
$255,000 a year but currently right now
it's
58,000 um so I can provide that data I
would also offer that I'm happy to work
with the Department on a revised um
fiscal note if they're willing based on
recent Trends on expenditures and the
total for the last fiscal year again our
$95,000 okay thank you for that was
no okay uh thank you very much so you'd
be willing to work on a fiscal note
absolutely we already connected with the
Department um so we all happy to do that
all right so we'll look for that for
additional information going forward
thank you um I hesitate if anybody's
doing um
amendments on this bill that there be
any sort of policy change to the
definition of disability or trying to
you know make up a definition for
delayed social or emotional development
I think in my opinion that crosses from
Finance to policy pretty clearly and
obviously just my three cents okay any
further comment on Senate Bill
596 okay with
that I have taken notes myself oh
represent walner um I I'm glad to work
on this one around the fiscal notes okay
and around the appropriation I think
that would be what we would probably
look at real good thank you very much
for that I have taken notes myself
summarizing basically the action items
for each of these bills going into
Friday we meet again on Friday at 10:00
a.m. in this room May 10th
uh I will send that around I'm going to
uh work on it tonight and send it around
in terms of what amendments we know of
to expect I know there's some additional
information that's coming and this will
hopefully formulate the discussion and
the agenda for Friday so if um anyone
knows of any further amendments or
anything that is missed in this lineup
or a thoughts you have prior to Friday
that would be helpful to include it so
that we can have a structured discussion
on
Friday anything further from the members
again special thank you to
representative Wier for taking notes for
a marathon session and unexpectedly no
less that was um very generous of you
and representative Leon covering today
and covering for representative wer and
of course Representative Steven Boyd for
being here all day and our division
three members for sticking it out all
day a lot of heavy topics once again and
um we will take them all under
advisement and onward we go to Friday
thank you all very much this will close